foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
yo yo
the realm talk to me what's going on my
check hello calculations back home it's
been a minute I have to come back from
NYC roll calling around right quick game
played over stuff I see you Gerald Mack
is going on Christopher Hart God of all
we in here today no doubt the dawn cgj
cjg you know what I'm saying salute
salute Castle what's going on bro you
know how the levels are sound and
everything is good oh I appreciate you
brother yo hustle my brother man I hope
everything is all right you know what
I'm saying recipes to once we lost I
mean I felt that much
[Music]
um yeah let's talk to
all hail the Lords I don't know who is
more better a jealous baby mama or free
R Kelly When it comes to care remember
to wipe your feet first wipe your feet
when you step up in the road salute
salute to R Kelly you're gonna say cows
we get to them
Gerald Mack the OG Bay Area what's up
five dollars to the chat all hail to IOP
salute the Lord through the Lord's think
or believe a conflict of interest makes
the deal easier or harder to get it
approved I know what y'all talk about
y'all talk about somebody real loose on
a Twitter
someone close to the organization
talking about my console
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
we had some fun today you know I mean
good some good topics tally up what's up
Rob C what up what's going on nah oh
hold on that's the homie right there
good to see you got the crest up and all
that oh all the way from NC okay okay
okay let's get this Supremacy God oh we
gonna talk that guy to walk Christopher
[Music]
[Music]
what's up is that g money from the
legendary flip the script is that g
money
let's go into it because
listen man it's a good day it's all
jokes it's all jokes it's all jokes
we're gonna get everybody we start a
little late okay just to clarify in the
chat with my uh God of War review will
go live uh after the show
and beat it yeah
it was a lot longer than I anticipated
what's going on so yeah we're gonna get
pick up ahead in a minute saw should be
rolling through okay I was chilling I
would solved last night Kai it was just
a shot the meds that pulled up to him
while I'm just got that uh wakanda
forever is so I will be strolling it you
know what I mean he had a couple drinks
and he was he was feeling good
oh yeah we'll get kick up here both of
them try to get y'all not too late then
but I had to fix the uh technical
difficulties shout out to add it to save
again just a little bit of messy show
with the settings that I was trying to
go live
anyway yo the best go get the king up
your hands off of me
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
it regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social lower
my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but that's all a part of me being a
cannibal and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to Freddie and
Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard the boy you ain't gotta say
it I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with and I'm going places better tell
her Uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
to be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
good
[Music]
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to an even though I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnido who cares if he flies he's still
a mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that joke you
never still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful
we'll let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord radio
[Music]
let's switch it over
all right hot bikes is all that
I do want to have a fair warning in the
chat uh-oh uh if I see spoilers in God
of War yeah you're gone
there's no if ads butts there's no there
will be no trolling with with God of War
in the chat I will get you up out of
there like real fast
here you hear ye and we are alive
welcome to the iron Lords podcast LLC
and also live on Lords of gaming.net
episode number 280 280 episodes y'all
yeah another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's date
and today we got that God of War
Ragnarok Impressions
Elden Ring versus Ragnarok Game of the
Year
Doom composer controversy itself
and Xbox One game pass to discuss so we
gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original gaming Knights of the
realm here at the round table my co-host
with Nicole most my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror Lord
of his old world and the how of the
young wolf Lord attic Ragnarok conqueror
how are you doing sir doing pretty good
um so yes I did P
um I did Peak God of War the review will
be going it will be premiering after the
show let me tell you one thing man that
that game's long it's a lot longer than
I anticipated
yeah and then I played that um what's
that game people were talking about um
which one vampire survivors yeah I
uninstalled that oh boy what happened if
you guys want to play a game
if you guys want to play a game that's
like that that I personally feel is
better try Loop here like it's like the
gay I can see why people like it I can
see why people are getting addicted to
that form of star but I'm just like I
didn't like that you can't actually
control your attacks like I don't mind
the I played moonlighters like I don't
mind what's going on but I don't like
how everything's like it's not that on
Rails you're attacked you're on Rails
and I I just I don't like that I feel
when I'm doing combat I want to be in
control of when I throw a fireball or I
throw a whip like I just feel like
there's too much I don't know I don't
know I feel like okay look you don't
have enough if you like it all the time
no but no see people look at people in
the chat Godly you control that stuff
mm-hmm
all right well it clearly is the issue
I need to press buttons
no I'm just saying I don't know what's
going on I'm just being super silly I
don't know what's going on I don't know
I'm not trying to say you wrong I just
don't know what the hell's going on oh
no I'm not wrong
anyways it's not all you would have been
controlled finishing uh God of War what
else would you be doing sir
um that's about all I I literally what's
funny is
my life was put on hold for that that
game
I I I got it I I streamed it for two
hours almost three hours Wednesday when
it came out then I played it like eight
hours the next day and like seven hours
the day after that
um and then I ended up staying up like
four what's funny is like me and my girl
she's like well it's time for bed I'll
be there in a second oh you hit it with
the one second five hours later no it's
four in the morning I'm like
you try to try to sneak back in the room
she was out she wasn't really
and then I woke up and right I was
towards the end of the game uh what's
funny is like that game you don't even
know you're in until it's like you're in
place
I have a PlayStation 5p don't be putting
that PS4 it's the fast go on how loud is
your PS4 wow no doubt that's been pretty
much it sir
yeah that's that's that's pretty much it
like um
you know
I'm more Curious with that Elder Ring
versus Ragnarok yeah
and of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo game will list for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus the Lord of clarity
and location of the iron bank my man
fresh off that wakanda forever with me
yesterday
I'm doing good man I'm doing doing
fantastic I I last night I when we got
back I was like oh I'm gonna do laundry
I'm gonna
shave
I just sat down in front of the
PlayStation
wait you got a PlayStation to play these
games I got a PlayStation five can you
believe it how how did you play and
enjoy these other games or other kinds
how dare I yeah Jim sent me one
personally you know what I mean you know
what's funny
enjoy this greatness you know what's
funny I set a uh I made a personal video
that was just like questioning if they
could hit all the cues that I personally
wanted them to hit for God for the right
and I had you know I had a couple people
that's like he's just mad because he
can't play I'm like what are you talking
about we're gonna get into that I
already know people got balls for that
that's hilarious
we don't have one okay
so that uh addict is wrong about vampire
survivors but I get it he's not of Our
Generation like I mean if you didn't
play Robotron or you didn't play berserk
okay you don't that's not for you if
anybody's games like those games thank
God I didn't play that yes thank God
that we they made a way for you to have
it for you to have all the nice things
yeah but uh uh last night got to see
what condo with the boys
um
I'm gonna start just calling it wakanda
but it was uh it was it was a very good
movie I going in I was just like hey I
don't how are they gonna do this yeah
and they did Justice to Chadwick they
did Justice to the character they did
Justice to name more yes
in a lot of ways he stole the show I
love that actor Tina Cortez very good
yeah and I didn't like his body at first
yeah at first
I accepted that he had the the Michael
Phelps swimmer you know body or whatever
but I needed I needed the six but you
know it's like it's like Hugh Jackman
X-Men one to like you know he's somebody
really grew into his space yeah exactly
I think that'll happen but go ahead sir
sorry yeah so that that was a good time
and just to be able to chill out with
the boys like I said I've been playing
uh played Ragnarok and Lady sound shout
out to my my baby she's coming back home
from piara today today but that gave me
an opportunity to play and then you want
to point out that that Saul's wife
ironically visited family when god of
war came here
it's like she asked because she uh like
you I think I'm gonna go at the
beginning I think 11. you see the better
time yeah you should go there so no
answer so happens it's my
mother-in-law's birthday so it fit
perfect oh yeah immediately but also you
know shout out shout out to the veterans
veterans day I had I had I had the day
off so I was like oh my goodness
the Suns have shined on you which is
never the case so I got to sit and play
and uh so I definitely didn't finish it
but I'm probably the the second furthest
in the game
um yeah we'll talk we'll talk we'll talk
we'll talk that was it no doubt and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer ooh the prophet of
Xbox Swami King of the statutes who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement
beloved Laura King how are we doing sir
I'm doing so good now that my DLC is
home
he'll see baby you see
this is the PlayStation 4. this is where
you know it started right and they
dragged their feet along
and they got me here the PlayStation 5.
some people can still play on the
PlayStation 4.
the 80 of you dudes I still get down and
that's what y'all talking from y'all
talking from the episode
King did you see that that uh video of
smooth posting trying to kill that Olden
Bird that's flying around it keeps
throwing the ax at it and he he just he
getting the PlayStation 4. I I maybe
because I know he's on a five but you
know I seen that gameplay maybe that's
the reason it's doing that it is what it
is but I wanna uh oh some man talk man
talk oh yeah we'll come back in a while
let's sit up what's going on out here
let me pull up this is ginger real let
me pull a little bit of Ginger I'm
hearing this I need to hear this stop
snitching for you dude why we need bad
talking
um
definitely necessary I had to do brand
us an Xbox podcast that we represent the
third place team and
um and why am I posting this because I
need oh we got a part taking greatness
people
brothers and sisters I want you to lean
in a little bit closer come to the front
of the congregation yeah King's talking
you you are leading nowhere
you are a consumer now I don't want you
to to lose self-worth because apparently
this dude that tweeted at me had lost
his worth he didn't know how much value
he has within this machine the
developers the Publishers they're
manufacturers and there lies us the
consumer yes
we have power but our with our dollar
buying this stuff none of that stuff
happens very true so he's talking about
game of the year is coming I said
doesn't do nothing for you game of the
year is coming doesn't put a nickel in
your pocket game of the year is coming
King and y'all ain't got nothing over
there I said I'm playing the same game
that you're playing brother aren't we
the same only on the same team
listen man
we are Gamers we are all in this
together in fact you look over to your
brother that's partaken this is no
exclusive Club there's no barrier
there's nothing stopping me from
Reaching Across the line and say excuse
me second I have my DLC
[Laughter]
were they popping off that that they
enjoy yourself you like well I would
join it too me too I'm just like you and
you are just like me
what I'm trying to tell you is tear down
these walls and these barriers that
you're building this invisible bubbles
that you're putting yourself in and
you're saying I'm not going to partake
of that because I feel like I'm doing my
team a desert you're by yourself when
you're shooting
when you go in your wallet and you take
out your wallet you're doing this
there's no team behind it
you got Jim Jim isn't behind you rubbing
your shoulders
what I want to say is okay
go partake man no doubt no doubt tear
down these walls these fake walls that
we building around ourselves I got my
DLC how about you faction facts you know
what's funny though like is is to me
it's like we on a block with them like
it's gay coaching it's like dudes we
really throwing it up for the set Bro
like they like yeah cause we out it was
like all right cool we we out too I'm
with you I'm playing and now you you
really mad whoa what's going on
you know what it is dudes be locking
themselves in
so what it is is now when because it
what it is is it's a reflection of how
they feel what the other side does
something and the other side of the
joint is they can't partake so they try
to project
people take it I'm just curious why you
guys are still like surprised
it's funny because we everything we say
here is ingest like everything it can't
could come here every single week and
rip a new one to PlayStation and you
better believe when that PlayStation
hotness come out why'd he turn his
camera off
yeah we're getting something about to
happen I don't know what he's doing so
you know it's just
okay it's all good so this is funny to
me like because y'all know this and
y'all choose to I I sometimes I some
people I know this they're dumb people
in this world people they're really
really buy into something but they
waited all year to do
instead of just sitting down playing the
game
song so there's a reason I beat that
game before they did because they they
sit on Twitter
I already know what he doing he bought
that guys
so this week what I was playing I was
playing my fortnite and I played a
couple of games off a game pass but my
DLC showed up
[Music]
and it came with a new controller so if
you're not playing your DLC
what's your new controller
there's a lot of more sensitive dudes
out there that I'm playing it before you
before you got a chance to get it before
you hardcore dudes got it where are the
receipts I told the dude I said where's
your receipt
you stopped tweeting
it's like no more attacks ladies where
the hell is your PlayStation 5. you stop
tweeting
oh man ladies the funny thing is it's
just like
I get it you know the the it's fun but
it's just like I put it to you this way
there's a reason I have the attic show
last week I feel that I feel that it's
like what when it came up and it's like
nah like I'm playing God of War I'm not
gonna go on a show and talk about God of
War like because to me that's
counterproductive like that I saw what
you said I like what you said he was
like yeah but Alex I gotta play these
games bro you know I'm saying these
games is outside respect
I felt away about that but how's your
ear infection
it feels better good
antibiotics oh and uh what is it Tuesday
uh yeah we will be talking about
uh hopefully we'll be talking about
wakanda yeah I'm a I had stuff happen
personally I think I could still go
watch it uh today so I think I am going
to be able to go watch it still today
okay so we'll be able to talk about it
Tuesday you know without anything else
sir besides plague no it's just it's
been fun life of gaming I I mean I
cannot wait to get to these topics
you said you mentioned Game Pass what
what did you try on Game Pass okay um so
uh signalus uh and I'm still was playing
uh ghost song so I saw the vampire joint
pop up in the popped up yesterday I
downloaded this real quick uh yeah
um oh no it's Alex talking about that
too he was going in on on
the God of War dudes disrespecting uh
the the vampire game
and there's a lot of people that were
disrespected not even just the God of
War dude there's a lot of people that
see a game and it's like oh whatever
that doesn't compare here's the thing
with that game like I see I'm not even
saying that game's bad it's just like I
played loot hero and when I'm playing
this it's just like I personally feel
like I enjoyed loot hero more like yeah
I could understand like leveling up you
get to pick a new tribute I know where
that addiction's coming from and I'm not
downplaying so we gotta break protocol
there yeah you gotta read it R Kelly I'm
very surprised by you gotta up yeah we
could have ten dollars
[ __ ] it up
King I'm sorry for ever doubting you but
I got to give it up to you God of War
Ragnarok was trash the writing was awful
subverting expectations for nothing I'm
a long time God of warfare I'm just
curious if like that's genuine or he's
trolling no he's like he'd be about to
smoke he put this in the um when we
promote it on the YouTube hey Ken you
know what I'm thinking though you know
what I'm thinking they like they let
people in prison play God Wars
he's in a day room he was in Remote Play
with a PlayStation 4.
um I heard is the best way to play
seeking the Vita in the Cell at night I
got I gotta respect chaos not not a lot
of you dudes is gonna even approach the
conversation and we I know we're gonna
get into it later but I gotta respect
your honest opinion or something because
I knew he was real because he didn't do
Kang
yo I mean
surprising no like if you like 2018 it's
kind of safe so far for what I played to
say that you're gonna like this it's
more but are you gonna like it
real quick though I want to point out
again once again no spoiling guys
don't talk about in the chat yeah oh
okay I got you no doubt no doubt no
doubt so uh that's it sir yeah that's
yeah no doubt and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the Shinobi Lord
Cognito spreading that realness in the
room and IOP not telling you what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to finding dude shout out to
Mr Maddie plays um actually he was um
not doing too well he's actually gonna
try I'll try to feel better salute to
him if that hell be down talking about
you know what I'm saying the whole
situation which we will get into as far
as the um doing composer some other
stuff going on I'm shout out to find a
new Ultimate which me and Maddie did we
talked about achievements we're talking
about overhauling that and so some good
suggestion there shout out to my man he
bartis the cheetah shout out to Travis
as you're in the building we have My Man
LEGO on which is talking about um
celesteo all the crazy this Destiny and
then it stated The Crucible all the
things they got to do for me of course
I've been playing that Ragnarok not as
much if I got the least hours as much as
everybody on the panel what's up man
real quick did you guys see that uh
picture of rev that went viral yes where
they put I saw it on Facebook
[Applause]
you know it literally went viral like it
was everywhere shout out to rev it was
perfect like he going in too he got some
days his son does look a little bit like
a joke
yeah they it was perfect we should have
got him on this we should have got that
boy yeah I was thinking about who we
could have invited we could have got
Rebel because rev is very passionate
about it it just I think whatever always
with me us and him is the scheduling
because I think I mean put his videos on
but I just it's just schedule it but
anyway so we got that you guys
I'm gonna just drop a
see what's going on there but yeah I've
been rocking that Ragnarok of course I
got the least hours of the panel here
but at least I want to get a discussion
um we are the low VR got um Iron Man VR
for the first time
that's the one from the PS4 right I
never had it so I never had psvr one
right so let's joint drive for the quest
I'm like all right let me see
is your hands to elevate just like Iron
Man and all that you got the repulses
and all of that and then like the thing
about it it's like it's telling us a
good narrative like yep like yo you're
doing the Tony Stark and I'm like yo
I'll tell you this though if you're a
motion sickness do not play this game
like you are Iron Man You're a movie you
put your arms back you out there you
doing the thing right and it's fast like
usually most days
what's up
people in the chat like mods don't don't
remove messages like get rid of them
okay don't time them out ban them okay
no doubt no doubt so anyway so we doing
that so I've been rocking that joint and
um two other games some under NDA can't
talk about it but I will be excited to
talk about them next week so we'll get
oh they um from The Meta Squad no no no
these are these are games from
other squads
we'll get into that but uh yeah we gotta
talk about I know it's been a minute for
combat talk but um oh yeah yeah rest in
peace Izzy on this one
um
bro I feel so bad for him you know what
this remind me of remember back in the
day there was a young Prospect he was
the next hottest thing this thing was
Sugar Shane Mosley
The Smiling boxes yes sugar shade was
like that dude he was the Untouchable he
was the Golden Boy undefeated record
really looked like the next thing I'm
not saying Izzy's not the next thing he
can't come back from this but I never
forget he ran up against another fighter
named Verdin Forest yes and we heard
about Vernon Forest who beat him before
whatever the amateurs and we like yeah
but it's different now because I was so
happy that and this situation with Izzy
and Alex Pereira and for those who don't
know this guy's like a K1 Champion you
know they forwarded kickboxer now the
first wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
yeah wait tell me you keep saying Izzy
is Israel
foreign
gets cut with a wild hook stretched
right in the chin like stretched it
embarrassedly the guys taunting him
doing all this stuff the third fight is
like the same thing bro like round one
Izzy caught dude and he was out he out
he was out on the street he was on his
feet if there was any more seconds Izzy
wins The Joint this fight goes on
and you just this guy he he's first of
all he's so naturally bigger yeah what's
his nickname
and them hands like he's just coming
and he just he just is he could get away
yeah the fading and then it was it was a
fruit it was it was dead it was uh that
was a perfectly Justified stoppage yes
um he was out on his feet he was moving
still but he was moving without he was
not looking he's not looking at him he
he had his head down just praying that
he wouldn't get hit oh yeah and it's
just one of them situations to solve it
you just know it like it's just a guy
that has your number and they talk about
running back and I'm just like
when you're an undefeated guy that you
used to be controller dominating like
yeah aspere is the greatest hater it's
like he left one sport to go chase you
down
and he seems like super humble like he
was like Hey you know he's like listen
I'm sorry for all the smack talking I
did you know as part of the game but
that's not me like I'm sorry for that he
apologized for like he just seems like a
good dude but he just has his number and
but the thing about it is if you look at
it like I remember how you said like I
don't know he might be in Izzy's head
it's obviously he's not an Izzy's head
is he I don't think maybe after this
fight right or maybe after this one but
I mean Izzy was in there doing this
thing I think the that two things that
are major to me for Izzy and and MMA
fighters
the hell we had a nice day talking to me
check it out I'll decide your catches to
do it over here right boom right so the
dude takes it ah in his head
he was out right he was out and the
referee stuffed in the referee said
cheer hold on wait a second
interactive referee don't go chill hold
on let me wait a second Allison gets
this dude out of here yeah so the
referee messed it up right let me give a
standing
here today he gave him back his energy
so this yeah so the standing is what it
was helped them in the in the fight
where he knocked dizzy out the second
time yeah dude Izzy had him on the
ground and he he got to stand in eight
and got got his mojo back he just this
is the ultimate pay to ref dude
we not doing that
I've seen UFC they let people literally
beat people to death yeah but if the
Bell goes ding ding round two there's no
saving
the man yeah boy
they gonna run it back out of field and
he waited I don't know why all right
this is the thing right it is material
before I had to go to sleep yeah yeah I
know
two things right it's called MMA for a
reason I understand Izzy with the hands
those guys like to you know be in there
listen if you want to stay with your
hands if you go back to kickboxing or if
you want to work on your hands right
boxing MMA utilize all the tools at your
disposal Izzy was Izzy was serviceable
on the ground like serviceable like he
he was able to move around get you know
get get into decent position to try to
like at least do some grounding pound
yeah but it looked kind of comedic
and it's like come on this is MMA use
all the tools into this boat I don't
care how good you are with the hands
somebody gonna come in one day be whack
with the hands like like tell me this
like a Damian Maya like a dick
in my grab Izzy up it's a rat yeah he's
done you know what I mean so that's one
thing two the whole fight I'm like Izzy
why is your back to the Octagon yeah why
is you why are you up against the cage
why are you not controlling the pace in
the middle of the octagon and you have
this man it didn't make no sense and I'm
like that didn't need to happen and he
says he hurt his foot but I won't go too
long with this but yeah man it was a
crazy fight yeah good fight we'll see
what happens on the next giant but yeah
so over kind of forever no it was last
night yeah it was crazy it was crazy so
that's it on that oh so I'm gonna get uh
super chats
no we got a super chess I'm hearing like
yeah that's pretty much it I don't know
good again oh okay super chats we got
Hector man five dollars Super Chat oh
hell the Lords I don't know who is more
bitter a jealous baby mama or free R
Kelly When it comes to the king remember
to wipe your feet first
and this is this is well but this is
before the Lord it's before exactly yeah
and we got Gerald Mack member for two
years five dollars per chat oh hell the
IOP salute the Lords do the Lords think
or believe the conflict of interest
makes the deal easier and harder to get
it approved but kicking them wasn't
there for that one that's why yeah yeah
which you think it's called interest
with certain people tweeting about their
console did y'all see the tweet no okay
um those guys from the the CMA talking
about it I mean
still being uh on his PlayStation
console your fear monger and your
control of the narrative and what you're
trying to do is push your bias on you're
gonna have to get up and use your your
vast wealth that you have attained by
taking bribes and get an ax so you can
play your games I mean again they I they
they went back and was like well he
doesn't have anything to do with this
process right this is his personal
account he could say what he wants on
his personal account yeah either way
like you know that you know don't look
good like you know what's funny though
if you would have said some off the wall
stuff about like something like
political it would be no it's his
personal stuff it'd be like no we gotta
give up out of there
yeah so I mean just it doesn't make a
whole lot it's just weird man it's weird
energy that you should know better like
I don't care if it is yeah you're right
at the end of the day even if he is not
a chief decision maker on the the deal
the APK deal as a Prof you you first of
how unintelligent is that like yeah why
would you even showcase any level of
bias or possible bias yeah a possible
bias on a public tweet so that was weird
to me again people some people say yo
he's not decision maker but he still
Associated for Clinton right and then
your party and that's the part was just
oh see which has coming in yeah okay
stuff kills kills I want you to I want
you to either put in a regular chat or I
want you to put in as a super it's up to
you but kills
um is this DLC or not
you
could put a super chat I just want your
opinion since you since you took an
honest pill today
before the pill run out
we gotta get to this topic quick yeah
hold on a second okay so we got a heck
to them I did that today
[Music]
um Cedric H remember for 29 months thank
you sir oh it's super and we got booty
remember for 16 months the original
enough respect
thank you
like Kells ain't do it he didn't do it
all like they still they Square they
they telling the truth
you wanna I I do want to address that I
saw a bunch of people talking about a
lot like we're aware that the last
week's audio wasn't the greatest like it
was our very first time ever coming
together like that yeah uh we we should
have did a little bit more preparation
of that but you know with anything like
that comes experience uh next time there
will be mics you can understand
our setup
the problem was is like we just expected
like studio type of equipment to be able
to be on par with our stuff that was not
the case this is the key to Ignition
Remix yo I'm still here
that proof said it wasn't that bad it's
not even if you could hear us or not
hear us it's just that's the kind of
stuff
we are expected you know to have
something else then and it wasn't there
anyway
let's get
good day Lords I'm really excited for
the special guest hutch from Call of
Duty man this is special I don't know
okay oh that's right
they say that you look like a character
from Call of Duty
okay okay
then we got true Kingdom member for one
year two dollars for chat King with
fresh knees and official price
sponsorship look down that's right they
give me the official price and he's back
there we go Sparkle 17 two pounds Super
Chat God the war joint was just DLC No
Cap I'm sorry wow there you go maybe
disrespectful delicious then we got free
R Kelly ten dollar Super Chat no
spoilers my critique subverted
expectations think of the last of us too
combat is too clunky still and they and
they have to get rid of that dumb single
shot camera beating our heads with some
tropes of 2018. wow
he's got more he's got more we got free
R Kelly Super Chat ten dollar Super Chat
for R Kelly dialogue was cringe if you
know you know this is the last game in
the north Saga and the whole time it's
very underwhelming because the writing
is subverted that's all that's all I
I'll say this is
yes so that dialogue part was yo I can't
have to wait till we get to the stop all
right we're almost there we're almost
there okay
dude
[Laughter]
let me see if I missed something I want
to make sure I didn't miss anything we
have 400 plus please
you walk into the house yes and share
that out to people that you know that
needs to have a laugh today because
you're about to get one no doubt no
doubt we all caught up sir yes sir all
right last week's IOP was votes oh what
the hell was that that was the Mr Price
controller
last week's IOP results are not in the
people have not spoken because we didn't
do it we was in New York so salute to
that we will be back on the poll
situation at the end of the show but we
got to get into these times y'all know
what everybody is here oh wait it's
still boys
get it let's get him down let's get him
down we got Mega bad guy 31 10 super
chat love that you guys entertain and
slip and slipping life lessons and
experiences soft talked about his
experience in baseball and some people
get the grind and some don't change how
I view the grind and life love y'all
thank you exactly until I took a
baseball to the forehead that was I was
a pretty good
use that dude
before it goes 17 too probably chat oh
Kelly here the heel turn with it
misspelled but fine thank you
shout out no shots
we ready ready all right let's get to
the main event y'all know what we here
for this is that Ragnarok so addict
we're gonna let you go man because I
mean part of me was like I should
probably go first because I got the
lowest game time out of everybody but
then the other part of it is that you
played it you have beat it and you got a
review that will be uh Premiere and it's
your topic Set It Off you handle it how
you win so God of Wars ragnarok's
officially out uh you know uh this this
gave meant a lot to me because I took
King's knees over it
especially significance to you
not an emotional significance
just know that King's knees are in this
closet
he takes them back from me okay so uh
what I really want to go over there is a
new setting in in YouTube that's like a
q a I'm gonna try that out with you guys
too just pretty much put in there you
can ask us questions uh that we can
answer just we won't go into spoiler
territory so if you're if your
question's spoiler wait we ain't doing
it uh but my but my my question to you
guys and I I kind of kind of want to
start with King because he he was the
biggest critique of the of the pastor
yeah
I just want to know what's your overall
perspective how long you have in it and
you know how do you like the transition
between the last game of this game we'll
start with that okay well um it didn't
end off like how it was supposed to
start off but it kind of threw me back
because
I was just like that's not how it ended
and I expected another scene but then it
built to that scene so it was a bridge
they put a bridge part two to get to the
scene where you actually really left off
at and um
and my my thoughts on is the betrayals
of the actual uh Norris characters that
they do introduce uh was a bit
underwhelming
because I didn't really like hip hop
Odin
um
that is a very good analogy using from I
did not like the way but I was spoiling
why what's the hip-hop part well because
[Music]
the only person who speaks like that in
the game is Kratos like and and probably
like mirror and stuff like that yeah
everybody else it's very modernish like
it's like Kratos in that little head
yeah they're the ones that stuck back
then yeah yeah okay everybody else is on
the new ship yo
cows is with you he said cringe dial I'm
shocked by this dude
Thor's hip hop they
the vernacular dude it threw me off so
much because it was like Prince he was
talking through
like the stuff that was said I was just
sitting there like okay I'll go with it
because this is what you want to do with
it and I'm cool with what you want to do
with your product it's for me to consume
and the story is being told
um they throw a mad caps at you right
now they said that Jack coping that
y'all did picking all right
what's the point of you got to be able
to criticize the things you love well
yeah I'm just mad because it's a 90.
yeah I got no 90. better I have to
completely 100 agree with King I do feel
like
especially Odin's voice did not
represent what I expected him to sound
like maybe it's because I don't I don't
have a whole lot of like mindset of how
Odin would sound like in a in that
actual scenario I'm not really sure
but he had a very playful Persona in
this game my vision I didn't see him he
was I mean I don't know how up until the
part where I got to he I only saw him
once and it he seems very like the guy
who plays him was in like the West Wing
he sounds just like him it's not like
he's doing the voice yeah he's doing his
voice he's doing his voice right and he
just seems shiesty he's shysty and I
think that part of Odin comes through
I'm not as offended by the by how they
speak the vernacular as as he wasn't
offended either but it is I get it like
because the thing is the game that that
gives the like the the comedic touch to
the game because Kratos is like a wet
rat I know this he
it's just like his opening thing he
pretty much says oh we got a problem
let's talk like I just I just don't like
that Demir like I I get it maybe that's
how Odin is in the actual World
technology of a a broke pimp
yeah I cannot jump in for my Liberty
gameplay I thought the opening was fine
okay
we're talking about Odin's voice yeah
when I was there he came through you
know what I'm saying you know when he
came I just felt like when I was
spoiling like to me it was like what you
call it where the oh do you know what it
is like when it when it's two two
gangsters right yeah and before two
gangsters step in the room and the
underboss would be like on some Bob
joint like let's see if we could settle
this right so to me it's the parlay
to me I thought they set the scene for
the parlay no no okay listen you know
what I'm saying something you don't say
so he got his son with him like yo you
go get the drinks go set it up you know
what I'm saying and then it's like
I ain't gonna be no parlay it's just it
is what it is
I'm not saying that I don't like that
what they did I said the portrays
betrayal oh okay
himself okay okay that right for me I'm
just talking about because you know he
asked me for me
so when when I started it up I'ma tell
you what was my little nitpick
of course this is my little nitpick My
Little Nick pic I don't want Odin to be
hip hop Odin I don't want people to be
Pimp C I don't want that right I feel
like or for Thor himself for me was much
like Eric the Red from the books yeah
perfect who's a good Thor right it was a
good thing people to say embedded in did
Chris Hemsworth though no it completely
destroys his voice
because this is Thor right how he leaned
into it a lot of stuff the conversation
that was into it the fighting was into
it I like that I like the fight I like
that right
um
I love the vistas when it got to to the
sprawling Vistas when you when you got
out I mean you know you still do the
same things the bottlenecks um how you
uh load in areas from one room to the
next all right so but I understand
because this is Tethered to the old
concept the PS4 right so you have to you
have to play it this way right so none
of the stuff in this box is being
utilized and I have to temper my
expectations when I'm playing it but
what I do like when I'm playing it okay
is I do like
um some of the towns that you see it
looks nice the water looks really nice
um the 40 frames per second yeah it's
it's it's cool uh and I play it at 60
but okay I mean we got it this game I
wouldn't do that absolutely gorgeous
though okay no I'm not gonna say that I
personally I'm not gonna say I'm
actually with King I think it looks a
little bit better than God of War 18 but
yeah just a little bit it's just a
little bit better than God of a god of
war and you can you know why AI it looks
like that because you can't go crazy and
and you know mess up the the actually
the premiere version is the PlayStation
4 version so you can't go crazy and out
work the pre the PlayStation 4 first you
just can't but what they did with
they did a very good job it's just
marginally better looking than um 2018
to be honest with you cry and they we
know why they couldn't go crazy now
these dudes are gonna say Oh Come your
cap it's this and it's that y'all don't
have a God of War who's y'all
first who y'all like y'all y'all is the
dude oh you talking about the
PlayStation 5 and the PlayStation 4.
that's the only thing that's separating
y'all
said something you is this five versus
yourself real quick real quick uh ham
said something that really makes sense
like he says it looks great but it
doesn't look new right it looks like the
same okay so Nate and they fixed a
little combat hair in a little combat
yeah you're not you're not impressed
it's DLC like I said it was
wow
after beating the game this could be a
DLC like a big expansion DLC
that's the thing is though that's not a
bad thing you know people get this like
large misconception of DLC some of the
best content that's in games have been
DLC is like 40 plus there's a lot almost
everything Bethesda makes is around that
okay it's just like when it comes to it
they didn't really change anything in
terms of Realms pretty much everything
uh they let you go to all the Realms
finally right which they answered a lot
of the issues that people
enemy variety your issue 2018 sorry
continue yeah yeah let me get to uh
let me get to some of these so we have
oh I can select them does it actually
pop up on there too oh it does it pops
up uh so uh Stitch said [ __ ] this game
have been delayed until next year no
this game was fine just how it was and
then we'll get one more and then someone
said how much of the game would you say
is cut scenes compared to actually
playing the game about 25.75 uh there's
a lot more gameplay than people act like
that okay
all right so uh yeah solve
um I can't disagree on the DLC part I
can't what I can't wait what is going on
today you know again obviously right I
mean we're saying it exaggeratingly and
that in that DLC because it is a 40-hour
whatever experience on its own
yeah y'all got the Caps I think I think
no no but I have to say like ultimately
means I think what real quick what king
also means is like it's DLC because it's
nothing new it's just more rehashing
it's more stuff it's more of this but it
was good the old stuff was good so you
don't really have to do a whole lot with
it so yeah when you look at it like it's
not the same this game didn't have a
seven year turnaround or whatever like
Last of Us Part Two did this is a
four-year turnaround okay and you know
so it would
that was expected and then seeing them
side by side and seeing them again last
week I played maybe like five hours of
the original God of War again on the PS5
just to kind of get a feel for it again
and to and going from one to the other I
was like yeah this one looks runs
smoother there's more detail in some
stuff but overall you look at it they
don't look all that different what about
the sled with the and then the snow with
the train that was beautiful
that was beautiful oh I was blown away
but that was beautiful but that was a
qte bro
I mean this game this game well here's
the thing though this game looks
gorgeous
let me address that you are getting our
words Twisted we never said the game
looks whack we said it doesn't look
drastically different than the first one
all right
gorgeous and I again all right so so
that's actually let's let's say
man Xbox series s right now is on Amazon
for 90 bucks what does that have to do
with the conversation
thank you send me one of those all right
thank you for that for 90 minutes
we could actually have consoles to give
away oh we gonna get that grab those
grados where you get a chance so look
look at finish your point because I was
good because my dig is like it's saying
you save right now
220.
bro
I'm dead serious my thing is I get what
y'all say in comparison to last year to
this year all I'm saying is what looked
like that this year that's messing with
this
what's the other stuff we're comparing
it to itself and I get it and all I'm
saying is it's a technical Master
apparently it's a scammer selling it on
Amazon
right now all I'm saying is when I boot
this channel it got shipped from fdhtra
yeah don't do it sorry the stuff that's
in your cart cannot be saved oh
everybody got it all right so so yeah
that's a scam y'all don't do it don't do
it yeah I was in it though
I tried to snatch five of them
it's like Little Bears lose
this thing Man it is just it's just
beautiful man it's the best it's the
best looking game that has come out this
year and like I said
well look better than this
okay well look better than this what
looked better than this this year for
anything what you going for what you
doing don't give me
that looks better but overall God of War
blows elderly thank you yeah but you got
to go from room to room I could just
just jump over there
okay
that's right
they got the 120 and play they got 100
places
100.
it ain't running one second
for PlayStation
conversation
what's in this conversation right now
because because Christopher Hart yeah
tagged me in comparison yeah yeah get
him get him so I don't know how like
because obviously some of these pictures
can be doctored I'm not two weapons
all right yeah we said that oh so
this has to be the new one God whoa good
luck yeah Lord
but then you got to look at uh Concepts
like this is a different region too yeah
but Kratos nipple looks better on the
right
don't don't get me wrong like okay this
is we gotta and this is a stupid cut
right at the end of the day it doesn't
go to the Crux of what the game is right
okay let's go let's go this is yeah it's
gonna be some it's going to be improved
I'm not saying it's not improved
when you look at them yeah it isn't like
it isn't when you look at Last of Us
Part Two The Last of Us one oh but
you're right so to the letter of the
Lord y'all write for me from the
difference from 2018 to this is not
substantial what I'm saying is but if
2018 raised the ball so hard it does
they catch up to this yet and it still
is the best looking enjoy you compare
themselves to their own greatness you
know what I'm saying
tissue doing to get to this level that's
okay here's one thing hold on let me say
I personally felt like Horizon forbidden
that way there you go Horizon zero Dawn
zero dog was a beautiful game back did
and when you play forbidden West it's a
noticeably difference
absolutely I would never that if you win
and someone would have said your call
for Horizon forbidden where's you at and
I ain't gonna front yeah
but I can't with you man
[Applause]
he's strong as hell right now but now
we're not going to do that
listen I feel y'all
going in though y'all going in like this
is got like two hours
I just don't like that like I I didn't I
pushed a button in the thing I don't
know if that actually turned it off but
it's just like I don't like having to
fight my controller to use it like it
makes no sense to me okay okay
um you know some of these questions are
wild I'm not answering them all man
someone said where did Odin get
batteries for his page
then someone said
there's um okay someone said there was a
lot of sitting around a table and eating
and talking in the first two hours did
that feel cringe to y'all or is it just
me that joke it's crazy
I love that I love the conversation
building in this game was good
well this is this is one of the few
games where I was walking yo I was
walking down and then like here's the
thing like in garnerable Ragnarok
they're constantly talking there's
banter always yes and what's funny is if
you go into certain areas the banter
stops I was finding myself oh I'm not
getting in the boat yet because I want
to finish this man story oh yeah
so first of all you know I play my games
wrong yeah yeah I know okay all right so
now that we got that out the way I I put
all that DS buffer and all that other
stuff real time on my game is running
very different play total let me get the
plateau rec room less looks phenomenal
is 30 frames per second Modern Warfare 2
yes that looks great I would say Modern
Warfare 2 looks great I'll give you that
Black Friday I ain't played none of
those games especially call it Call of
Duty I don't know but I don't I don't
consider them but I think Cod is another
example when you look at it when you
really when you look at it you have to
really look deeply at that game and be
like okay to see the differences when
you look when you put them side by side
it runs it plays like a card game right
it so it's kind of the same thing here
where it's like you put them side by
side it really takes you got to take a
moment to really care about all I'm
saying is giving that graphical
we got a situation
free R Kelly says can I come on
look here like we we have to vet people
before we just stay away
I'm not saying that you gonna come on
here and say crazy stuff R Kelly I'm
saying I don't know if you're gonna stay
crazy
it just at the end of the day
no added killer you're killing me today
really okay
all right
sounds anonymous
this door you're good
at the end of the day the graphics are
the last thing you're gonna remember
about this game it's beautiful you'll
remember that fire cool
where I sit on the gameplay okay let's
go
is ultimately the changes that were made
from the first one to this one
that's that's where the DLC thing comes
in and where it rings true where there
are improvements to combat there there
are improvements to how sort of how you
level up but the end of the day it's
more of the same okay and that's not a
bad thing okay but it isn't
transformative It Isn't So and then when
you look at the narrative stuff The
Narrative stuff is this a lot of people
come out Masterpiece greatest of all
time comparisons to movies like to some
of the greatest movies of all time
no no no no no it's just not it's just
not like I I enjoy I enjoy the
conversations between these characters
because conversations feel authentic
right the Korean stuff I get what R
Kelly's talking about and what king and
attic talking about where it's like yo
they don't feel like they belong in this
time period they're talking like they're
from the hood or whatever I get it 100
I like the Lord but Thor Thor is kind of
that middle ground right he is that like
he's he's gangster he's gangster
exactly I love that about it
but those conversations like just later
later on you'll see there's
conversations between atreus and and
craters where you see the rebelliousness
and the teenager and the trails and he
like he tries to talk to his dad like
strong and the creators is like and
creators is like who do you think you're
talking to like who you think you're
talking to like you know he does he's
like he it's like he addresses what yeah
he tries to say it crazy
he addresses whatreia said and then yeah
I know I don't care he addresses what a
try he said and then he was like but
don't you ever talk sir
it's noticeable from from first game
whereas he was a child growing the
relationship changed right growing up
into it and
Kratos is learning as a father he has to
give him a little bit more space because
his Natural Curiosity as a child take
him in a direction where his father well
his step daddy
is telling him he can't go so his
rebellious nature in learning uh his his
own boundaries is being seen through and
it was shown very early on uh when a
certain event happened and he wasn't
present at a point and you know certain
certain things had to be engaged you
just said a spoilery thing King so no I
just said certain events was present no
no no you shouldn't spoilery before that
all right we're gonna act like we're in
here
we're gonna act like we're gonna hit
that continue
um
yeah so to me it's just one of those
things where it's a very very good game
I am enjoying and much like the first
one
I it's one of those things I don't want
to play anything else I want to play it
I I every time I'm thinking about
playing it and finishing it and getting
through the story and seeing what this
concludes your name you're addicted yeah
oh for sure for sure I absolutely wanted
more of the same but you can't stop
playing it
it is I mean no it is it is popcorn
Blockbuster it is it is the peak of like
polishing but you speak
that the dialogue in this game is better
than Red Dead 2 you bugging oh that's
what this is
so
he riding for that one
right
now
I like Gamers listen we've improved
considerably where we're at in terms of
in terms of narrative we've we've we've
Leaps and Bounds absolutely absolutely
absolutely the problem is that when you
start when you create a narrative game
right then you are beholden to certain
things of Storytelling right absolutely
and the problem with that is in a game
in a game that storytelling has to stop
for the gameplay to happen right and if
the pacing is a little bit off or
whatever it doesn't it kind of it does
disservice to the narrative because you
you can get lost in like you know you're
thinking games like it's like oh the
world's about to end but I gotta go find
these 50 things yeah you know and and
and so this game still has that and I I
love that minutia I love finding the
little things and so far the side quest
stuff that I found in this game is such
that it's like it's Story related enough
where it's interesting for me to do it
okay um so all that stuff is improved
I'm just saying like when I hear people
out here like the greatest ever and it's
that the other it's just like I'm not
I'm not there it's great but it is it is
it is derivative of itself you know what
I'm saying and again fair enough I I
feel everything you said what I was
gonna my only pushback because
everything you're saying I get my only
pushback is because you're saying the
advancements of narrative in other games
and where it has come
maybe are do you think maybe you're
being a little too hard being the fact
that it's Kratos and let's be honest
he's not the most conversational guy
he's not the you don't say that they
have the limitations on the character
tropes sure right so you're not gonna
get this crazy disposition no you know
what I'm saying yeah but they had they
have mamir for that they have atreus now
for that summer for that right yes and I
just think
the best parts of conversation that I've
seen happen in the boat happen when
little comments kind of just pop up yeah
and the stories start to flow and those
back and forths work or the back and
forth that I like between Kratos and the
trails where
atreus is you know again he's being a
teenager and he's excitable about things
and cradles cradles trying to ground him
right great was trying to ground him but
like yo man you bugging here like okay
he running into he running head first
into things that could be dangerous he's
like yo you're not you're not thinking
straight right and and that stuff as
opposed to the overarching narrative at
least to the point where I am now is
more interesting God right okay I got
that I got that that's fair that's fair
so yeah real quick IGN is over there
so all right I do
I did tag a question yes uh and I feel
like we all could answer this yeah so
about opening being similar to 2008
openings slow start adds to a house
fight some you know regular enemies
someone makes an appearance epic fight
uh first off I want to ask like I like
this question what do you think was
better this one or 2018 and they are a
lot of
[Music]
because on here you kind of got a a
sense of what was going on when I played
18 in this random dude knocks a little
ax all strong and I'm just like dude do
you even know who you messed
this little skinny crackhead looking
dude
let's dust this dude off in the fact
that he was taking shots and uh fighting
back and breaking up the world it was
like oh who is it just fine I can't stop
this one you already knew who that dude
was you already knew what power caliber
he was in
um you just wanted to see how it planned
out but this one the first one was more
of a surprise and it was more of a setup
it was more of a shock this is more of
the same okay less of a shock yes and
this is why it comes off as DLC no I
don't think I do think that second fight
is still good I just think that oh yeah
yeah the surprise of that first fight
right is what gave it the edge okay
let's see where y'all go I mean I can't
really push back too much I I admit I am
a fan of the second one more but it's
more so because of the names involved
right yes yeah yeah to your point if
there's no first one then it's literally
like did take the Trope and then they we
managed to run it right so I give you I
can't put your own song y'all argument
is stronger than mine this is cog's
personal bias because Cog likes when the
heavyweights get down right it's it's I
mean besides the people of us what
happened why are you laughing at me it's
super chatted so they should have called
it God's in the hood
stop it
it's such an epic matchup based on the
names right like like can you saying but
to me is nothing more gangster and
cold-blooded than Nepali when you got
two people who could literally
obliterate each other right but we gonna
try as as G's to settle this and make an
arrangement so I like that portion of it
I know it I call them hip-hop Odin and
all that I get it but I guess the reason
I disagree with you is I know the reason
all that happened so yeah you know
you're farther than me you you got way
more context I give you that you'd be
like God wait till you find out then
you're going that's gonna sour a lot I
get it I'm just saying for me it just
was like man like I always wanted to see
and then millionaire and then yo I'm
like
and then I gotta be real the reason why
I still give it over for Ragnarok over
that just that part
it's
I hear what you're saying that was built
up over a period of time you took four
years facts to anticipate that fight the
hottest fight is going to go down facts
so when they started it up and it wasn't
right at that fight first of all I was I
was like what what the what what
happened here wait you know so and
shout out to Sony for making me change
my name
put that in the chat yeah
um hold on let me give that to y'all
right now
um
I'm so pissed off with Sony that I lost
my two games that I brought digital from
and I should have never trusted them
ever but my friend lost like 40.
I had to change my name so y'all can see
my name right now y'all can go Abby
right there that Xbox lover Game Pass
okay so it was nothing
PlayStation Network get out there I have
no trophies I had nothing I'm backing yo
they gotta stop they call it gods in the
hood
when Odin came through I thought
something else and then I saw Mr Furley
from threes
Mr Furley came in with the hip-hop
presents
you know this is yeah
that's my love you know what I'm saying
I talked to my love about that b I'm
like what's going on here I'm like first
of all I said Somebody's trolling the
hell out of me right now then and then
yo make it quick B
okay so I can't do this man all right I
give you the olden portion the old
important portion is is a little
different than the the different a
little take on it you thought you look
you had to look down in his feet to see
if he was wearing Yeezys
who has infiltrated my game
who touched my DLC like I said I said
this should touch my deals
did y'all see Sherry win Yeezys
oh man y'all too funny but anyway so we
got most of that out and then I was
gonna move it to the main event unless
we got more we got our pressure yeah let
me let me answer some of these questions
all right so can he jump no stitches
Jay wants it isn't God a word 2018 like
Infinity war and Ragnarok like in game
um I think that that's a decent analogy
but I don't think like I feel like
Infinity war was a way better game than
2018 I mean movies in 2018. there's more
build up there's a lot more movies going
to that I don't I think that the ideal
is a fair analogy but I don't think like
you can actually compare it like that
um and then we get we will get one more
Charles R says power book five got away
so now we in a rich Big Town this is the
last big [ __ ] down
God says do you all prefer the older
style God of War games or the new ones
for example God of War 3 is the goat in
oh man uh to me and Kratos is this rage
fueled uh Hulk Hogan was literally went
through the wall uh went through the
gods one by one
um I prefer the older ones yeah that's
my question added question is there any
moment is there a moment in this game
where you feel it compares to the
opening of God of War 3. no there's
nothing in any God of Wars that compare
and we'll say this or ask you without
because obviously you beat the game
you're one of the only people I know
let's beat this game this game is what
would you say 25 30 hours how long how
long did it take took me 28 hours 28 now
okay so 28 hours keep in mind I I did
miss a lot of the size stuff uh so
because here's the thing like I'll do
the side so there's conditions for me to
do side activities okay once you gotta
you gotta like lure me up like pretty
like to gotta butter me up to do
something you got to be like a legendary
weapon that we need to go
something that makes me feel like I
gotta go get this all right they do a
bad job in this game second off I got a
I have to be more interested in what the
actual winnings of that mission are than
the actual main story of the game
because if I'm
vibing with the main story more than I'm
vibing with all that side chat stuff I'm
gonna go do that I was so intertwined
with the story of God of War Ragnarok I
ain't care about none of that side stuff
but I will say this a shout out to G
Park on feel better about he was
supposed to be on today we're supposed
to have a buddy he wasn't feeling you
know Gene Park actually had an interview
he said that he gave Ragnarok some of
the best side quests in the game he said
[ __ ] get this off you were with your guy
he said the side quest in God of War
Ragnarok had finally dethroned side
quests in which the Witcher it's got the
ones I did do were good I had to do a
couple they're they're good I think the
only thing I missed from the 18 one is
like the valkyrie thing where like
there's things around the world that's
like in-game content now there are some
of that in this game but I feel like
those Valkyries and what I really like
before we move on is I like the fact
that they acknowledge the first one they
acknowledge the original trailers you
sometimes you'll be going out in the
boat and they'll just be talking about
stuff that happened in God of War 2. and
keep in mind manir like all these people
in North mythology they heard rumors of
what happened with Kratos and God of War
one two and three yeah so when they're
referring to the situation it's like
it's a fairy tale it didn't happen
they're like yo did that really happen
like that seems very far-fetched he's
like no it happened
there's like a journal that you find
that's like journal entries and
somebody's like the Ashen God and it
talks about what he did and it's like
and they're like oh he he killed all
these people like like they're like now
yeah yeah Kelly came for me he said
don't disrespect The Witcher like that
I'm just telling what team box say
that's my face so Kelsey beat this
already I mean it feels like he beats
his character like he fall he fought
like he fought oh I mean you got nothing
but time when you buy bro
it is what this game excels at the most
is is building the lore making you want
to care what happens in the world it's
like I said sometimes you you're just
those random banters is better than
anything going on in the story and it's
a lot about Nostalgia obviously like you
know what there's a time in the game
where they're talking about something
that happens god of war 2. and I sit in
the smile only I remember that and I
think I think what makes it work for
them also is the fact that it's not an
open world it is what they that little I
love about her not an open world it's
like a hub World
linear wide is what they call it squeeze
into this area
squeeze into this area
no because I mean somebody online and
this is and this is fair so far as to
what happened
five percent 95 God of puzzles and five
percent got them if you're not squeezing
into a tiny space you're and you're
lighting something lowering under
something right there's a lot of panning
going on in this and what's funny is I
saw Erica she said I played nine hours
and I think I've actually had combat for
an hour and a half to two like something
like that everything is puzzle based
everything is
yeah don't let down grab that gold take
it over to the to the the trolls pull up
your weapon squeeze into this area fight
these women I'll say I'll say I will say
this uh when it comes to like the
puzzles and God of War Ragnarok they're
like it's like they're sitting in a room
they're like we really liked making
those puzzles and out of War 18. they
were easy they didn't take much time
they're like we got to do something
different let's just add one thing to it
let's use those exact puzzles and do
something different yeah it's crazy it's
like half the game is the exact same
puzzles and then they put another
mechanic in it to make them slightly
harder but it's not really harder it's
just like it's just like princess
I've heard a lot of people complaining
about the fact that um create uh atreus
and mimir give you the hints
to be honest I'm like I don't I don't
care and I I used to care about stuff
like that I don't care anymore so I walk
into a room they're like yeah maybe you
should do that like that no doubts
I'll be walking I'll walk up and they'll
be like yo I I I I need this Hammer I'm
like go get it then before we switch it
with actually so I'm just made me think
about it it's a very controversial thing
going outside the BG Weber will there's
a controversial thing going on about the
accessibility aspects and and we're in
reference to
um trophies right so from my
understanding and you correct me if I'm
wrong at it is that if you choose to
hire difficulty trophies there's no
there's no difference as far as like
when you end the game nothing says that
you ended at this difficulty and that
seems to be a little bit of a concept if
I remember correctly there wasn't a
trophy in the first God award ATV right
I want to go put it on super easy it
seems like nothing's gonna stick you out
like nothing it seems like Sony is going
a little bit more with the let's broaden
our Horizons to have as many people do
trophies as possible that's right and I
don't mind that mindset but it's just
like at the same time like why would you
put these difficulties in a game when
there's literally nothing like you're
giving nothing for beating these things
and and God of War on 18. I I I played
on the one before it but God of War on
18 particularly that was a that was
annoying right and I I think that that's
a really
that's a gray area that's a genius move
but it's a tough space to navigate
because it's like all these dudes don't
want their trophies now I got the same
trophies you do
it's a tough space to navigate because
it's just like
people who are not accessible to these
type of games you know people are
disabled they can't play these games
should they not have access to all the
trophies part of me is like you don't
have to have all the trophies and then
the other part of me is like why
I don't know
why I'll say the controversial I'll say
I'll I'll dial my son look I'm all about
accessibility options you know what I'm
saying um I'm always gonna fight that
fight and for the for the Existence to
be there but I am tied to develop a
choice and I am tied to how the
developer wants to handle his game
whether it be difficulty or whatever it
was funny is I'm not even a Souls guy
like I'm the guy that actually need to
help in Souls games so you know for me
to to Champion for from to say hey we're
going to keep it this way we're not
giving you no because like God if you
look at ragnarok's accessibility options
you can literally turn off the puzzles
you can you can make this and it the
most easiest experience is just pure
story if you choose I'm cool with that I
will admit I I am bothered by the trophy
aspect because there's one thing to let
everybody they haven't been doing with
their games at all lately like Last of
Us Part Two I don't think I had one and
I get it this is the direction they show
I do feel a little bit away if someone
picks the hardest difficulty and when
they end it there's no recognition of
that on a trophy level I I do feel that
though they should get something that
that's just one it's supposed to be it's
actually still inside I can't get it
it's actually worse because gone uh Last
of Us Part One the original one had
difficulties for every trophy for every
difficulty and when they remade it to my
knowledge because I didn't buy that
right they took all of that out like
there's no trophies for difficulties
like it's like I said it's a gray area
because like at the same time I want
everyone to have access to it but that
but it's like are you literally going to
give No One Rewards
that's all I'm saying that's his whole
life inside yourself
look I know it's a controversy the
personal accomplishment so personally
what happens if if you gave them the
accessibility options
but you let them take it to those higher
difficulties because I feel like you see
but then we have a section of the
internet that's going to use these
trophies to attack people right that's
right we take that away so you know it
part of me feels like
the majority of people that actually
want I don't care about that stuff and I
play it all I play everything on neither
normal or the one if I'm very familiar
with the formula of your game I'll play
it on the one before the last never play
anything right now right
and part of me part of me is like the
only real reason that you would
realistically want these trophies to be
mad hard to get is if you want to use
them to validate them and to check
people that didn't do it right because
to me if you're a Trophy Hunter you
don't want none of that nonsense you
want the easiest trophies you could
possibly get so yeah it's just like
there is that sense of accomplishment as
a scales is going in yeah as a as a
person that you know is highly skilled
to say hey I did this very hard you
shouldn't be able to say that is enough
I feel like the only reason you want the
trophies because it's validation I got
it yeah yeah no absolutely I'm not gonna
say it's not it's validation of skill
level there's no doubt but what I where
I counter is that I say it's for for the
people who say you know um people access
my thing is I thought the issue was that
you weren't able to even attempt these
um games in the first place so we're
making it so that yo you could you could
get in no one's going to be excluded
from playing a difficult game you know
what I'm saying and I thought that was
the fight and I'm all for that I want
everybody that could play could play you
know you just think it's going too far
it's like leaking into the trophies the
difficulties yeah I just want the guys
do who now everyone's included
everyone's at the door everyone can play
right right we got to the level that we
wanted to get there's no one that is not
allowed to play this game at a highest
difficult all I'm saying is for the
people who do put in that difficulty I
do feel there should be some
acknowledgment of the completion at that
difficulty that's all I'm saying I
remember I I didn't I can't remember I
think you got a shield if you beat God
of War 18. thank you perfect they did do
something in there perfect day like like
whether it be the the armor color emblem
even Destiny does stuff sometimes like
that you get it exactly just something
to show that that person did that
because it is we don't want to minimize
that sorry I I remember there's been
times where I'd be in the disc scored
with like BG in them and they'd be
talking about this and I think it's a
shield right if I rumor credits the
shield and I would just hear BG black
show me that Shield then brah show me
that Shield then make sure you beat that
game no doubt but look we go we go along
with this and um let's get the super
chats and then we'll get to the main
event because I want to transition right
to the baby
just he just wants to to talk down on
Eldon ring that's all he thought
there's no conversations
[Laughter]
we having that conversation we in there
and and Carl comes in man we got a
problem but we we have a solution and I
just stand up like no
yeah yeah yeah that was oh you just yeah
that was the joke okay so all right
Apollo Cooper two dollar Super Chat oh
didn't even said No Cap in the game
[Laughter]
wasn't on the writing tip that's why
anytime they put Ragnarok in a title it
ends up being mid Thor Ragnarok was
trash okay okay okay there we got three
R Kelly five dollars Super Chat and one
last thing this was built for PS4 this
is not next gen I played on PS5 and the
whole time I'm wondering when am I going
to see next-gen-ish
I said that the whole time I'm looking
at my PlayStation 5 like and you
breathing hard over there
you guys
all right
come on
that's so biased
Godly ring the other game
I'm gonna take it down that was a joke
I'll do it I already voted attic then
we got uh Simon McKenzie five dollars
which Ragnarok was good but I think it's
time for Xbox to take over next year
uh let me see if we are Kelly Two
Dollars to chat my ex if you know you
know yes I know right Odin did say my ex
my ex
what buddy really
uh then we got free R Kelly Two Dollars
they're subverting expectations for no
reason
wait no listening to the whole joint he
said big bong like New York
when he did it like this
yo yo yo yo King King this is what was
going on during all that time they said
they're talking
he's like man look at that ax that looks
so clean
I just don't remember the big
story
get him out of here
I can't oh this is yo don't take those
don't take too long
[Music]
that's all you're looking for is a
different city but graphically it goes
up little by little I do feel DLC is
slanted though connotation of DLC
disrespectful it's disrespectful
how many DLCs for games turned into
their own separate product where it's
like no it's too big to be a DLC we're
going to see we're going to switch it up
and make it a full release on his own so
I mean I'm sure some of the stuff in
this game maybe would have been in the
first game yeah a lot of negative kind
of things as as God Bing Bong
said wow my Super Chat not red Mr
Nichols
Mr Nichols
the this this is the two dollar suits
half of spaced over again the series
that's 90 right now you almost got us
all uh brought it out thank you then he
came two dollar Super Chat y'all capping
every sequel's DLC then buy that logic
okay what's the problem why does why
does me calling this game DLC affect you
in a minute and you got to look at it
you gotta look at it real hard you want
it to be its own little boy so bad it's
a real boy he's a real boy it's real DLC
and one dude said you can't say that
King I paid for it it's whatever I want
it to be
it's your opinion exactly you can paint
the narrative how you want that's fine
we good and we got platano J member for
one year two dollars to protect just
looking Lord God of War is eight for me
okay the eight for him
DLC then we got free okay here we are
Kelly ten dollars let's keep it a stack
this is a PS4 game the new Realms are
two Realms at best every other realm is
old assets even the final realm is just
a end game one time realm this should
have been PS5 only okay he's not
entirely wrong there like we did go to
other Realms but it was very limited I
will say that some of the newer things
was limited it's not going to be PS5
only there's 150 million places for
there's only 100 and this game is
selling well it wouldn't have sold well
150 million out there
this game is selling well too it
wouldn't have sold like that if it was
only on yeah it was um already the
biggest launch in the forecast history
in the UK it'll be the number fourth
number one for the series
Mr Nichols five dollar Super Chat
Guardians of the Galaxy look better and
and do a comparison they got better
gameplay
he says Guardians looks better in
comparison and it has better gameplay
they look good in spots you talk about
two different games though I mean it's
still just it has more characters on
screen more banter you hit two different
formulas two different games you can't
judge
I mean it always it's always going to be
that right it's always apples to oranges
because they're all different products
comparison the best comparison is 2018
to this one yeah that's really the best
you can make
akw five pound super chat a playtail
Requiem had a better story than God of
War but I just want to say had great had
a great show have a great show Lords one
of the best non-nada Xbox bypass like we
talk about PlayStation game dudes is
playing this is bad
this uh the shroom Kingdom God's in the
hood thank you sir that was fantastic
then we got Metro night five dollars
which I got a war only looks slightly
better if you're on performance to be
honest if you favor Fidelity only
Horizon forbidden West is touching it
when you say gears is DLC yes yeah I am
I mean Hive Breakers is literally yeah
and I'm sorry I'm not playing it on
Fidelity and playing at 30 FPS
yeah I'm playing on performance yeah no
doubt no doubts
thank you very much we got you bro Mr
Nichols Spartan goes 217 two props we
said Odin was Two Steps From saying
where you're Shorty at
like I remember you boo like what kid
so uh for R Kelly again ten dollars
which at God of War Ragnarok fails
because Odin and Thor was subverted
balder was a good villain because the
player wasn't forced to empathize with
him you could but you weren't forced
Thor and Odin were underwhelming okay
too early to tell you I'm I'm still
processing the game right and
I can't say what he's saying is wrong
because it's subjective but it's he's
right in a sense the Bolder aspect of it
is break it down we could have cared for
him or we didn't have to we can care for
his mom's ride because yeah because the
moms are like that's just don't kill my
baby whatever it is just don't kill my
baby type of thing so we can we can feel
for her pain I thought bolda had a
bigger claim for fighting him and they
seem so evenly matched but the only
thing that gave uh cradles to Edge was
his Weaponry yeah be honest with you so
then when he fights this individual the
Weaponry seems a little bit even okay I
don't know I I just feel that we were
taken by surprise and yeah
said that best that
he thinks that the next one when he was
on the show with us because this before
it came out right because I didn't watch
his review yet because I didn't play the
game and I just don't want it to be
spoiled for me but um he felt that we
won't be surprised like we was from the
first one and I and I think that's
what's transpiring now so I think a lot
of people went into this with different
expectations and the expectations was
too high but then they got in it was
just like oh it's just like more of the
same but a little bit better so yeah I
don't know I think they're struggling
with that part of it yeah because that's
that's not a bad thing like we said a
million times it's not a bad thing but
it is it is you don't you're not you're
not going to relive those moments of
when you first saw the other one playing
you're like wow they really changed God
of War like you're just not gonna feel
that again
as far as like Odin and Thor if they
were like underwhelming
I say yeah uh they they were
especially once you like beat the game
yeah you realize there's a lot of missed
opportunities that would have been very
epic but they uh I don't know maybe they
ran out of budget I defer to you there
you're the one that finished it so you
know where this thing goes so but it was
still a good game like people what's
funny is all they're going to say is
people are going to see attic talking
this negative I had to talk that naked
but they don't talk they don't talk
about when I talk positive about the
games like I
I really enjoyed god of war and you know
there I I went in a huge detail in my
review uh keep in mind that we'll be
going live
uh so you know stay around for that I'm
not gonna really talk too much more
about it no doubt songs
uh Spartan goes 17 Tupac addicts saying
the God of War got Thrift Shop mechanics
damn I don't know no no it's just the
puzzles I felt like could have been
Broad and more they could have fixed it
up a little bit more that's all like if
they weren't bad but you know especially
what Erica said between the panning out
left and right the cut scenes and the
puzzles there is a lot less time you
actually are fighting yeah
uh shroom Kingdom once again two dollar
Super Chat another movie reference get
Odin or die trying yeah
I got free R Kelly five dollars with
that beat it on give me God of War mode
and this isn't a spoiler but this game
has checkpoints on bosses this is a
blasphemy Alden ring would never oh I
didn't do that yeah but I ain't gonna be
real be real with you
there was one particular fight well I
died I'm like man I gotta start over and
then when I saw the hell down a little
bit okay yeah yeah
was listen like I said I don't mind any
of this stuff I'm getting old the
reflexes aren't the same you was good
with the accessibility when the trans is
like when the trash is like yeah it's
over there
I think they do that with this one uh
because it's just not PlayStation 5 only
and you can't call up those squares you
know they had to Help Me Howard squares
yeah yeah so and the PlayStation 4 can't
do to help me out with square yeah and
not to mention they tell you when you
should Dodge
the outline now that was in the first
one though right mamir calling out
I don't no like I'm talking about the
visual aid I don't remember it was there
the arrow was there too maybe maybe I'm
wrong because it's been so long since I
I played that game like real from
beginning to end but I don't remember
them telling me when they're grabbing
like when I have thought and they're
about to do like a Grammy
when it shows up blue you have to use
the shield I don't remember that I don't
like maybe though the yellow one and
white and red one was that I think those
watch out for the fire brother I made it
I made it more difficult for myself
I got the Parry Shield you know me and
the parries right so yeah the Parry
Shield is considerably harder than the
regular shield because the power shield
for parrying it's not you can't really
sit there and absorb damage like a
regular shield you got a parry and then
you got a double hit where you can like
shove them with your Shield yeah but
beyond that it's uh yeah you got to be
on point with the blocking and the and
and he sound like the dude from Destiny
that'll make you rich brother
yeah we got free R Kelly again five
dollars Super Chat
um I'm hurt God of War is dead this game
is a journalist wet dream I don't want
to watch a movie I want to kill Gods I
mean
because that's a huge that's literally
where the directional [ __ ] went right
from 2018. yeah
they thought it was going to do a
comeback don't call it a comeback not
some people who are fans of the original
may make struggle with I understand that
mindset I mean all right continue okay
sorry is three dollars Super Chat top
three gaming Studios and why that's a
long ago I'll give you one I'll give you
one my obsidian Bungie I can give you
three okay Microsoft Sony and Nintendo
Rockstar Rockstar
I'm reading Rockstar okay
uh flame five dollars Super Chat wait
Thorin ordinar and God of War Ragnarok
spoilers
exactly you're kidding since I'm an
expot I'll be there uh I'll be the one
to Die Another sword I am more like God
of War oh did you have it sir Florida
[Laughter]
Super Chat thanks for the great content
Thor I am Lawrence thank you so much
five dollars for chat Elder ring is
going to win game of the year because
many people enjoyed it games don't need
to have the best graphics or story to
win Seafood is my game of the year
foreign
can we move on and talk about God of War
taking this silver medal ring we're
about to yeah
real quick real quick next week because
they're announcing the nominations
guys stop guys stop stop ain't happening
we gotta destroy yourself I gotta get my
first belt I ain't never won but anyways
so big over I guess you know you know
what I feel like we should do one of us
should vote everything Saul does and the
other one should vote don't do that
don't do that I would I think y'all was
like whatever soft doing we do it
y'all ended up doing it so I'm like
outdoing itself and pick something with
you over or over analyze yeah so here we
go y'all so this is the talk man you
know Ragnarok is out in these streets
highly highly rated critically acclaimed
you know I'm saying the Metacritic
popping out here but there was this game
at the top of the Year dominated to
Zeitgeist from software took the sold
formula in the open world so you know
the kegleys are about to be announced he
just said that the world game of what
Game of the Year Awards is coming and
this is the talk you know and I just
wanted to set it up because I'll be
honest
and y'all know I'm not a Souls guy yes
but I know what Elder ring did right and
Elder ring was so dominant
that to be honest I didn't think
anything could even remotely be in the
conversation I'm with you we knew God of
War Ragnarok was coming but for me to
even say I was like okay if that I don't
want to feed it to the DLC talk but for
me okay it's probably gonna be good but
is it going to be what Eldon ring did
right and this is the discussion so I
want to start with attic first because
obviously you've beaten both games you
know which is an extraordinary feat you
know what you call is extremely long you
know so uh what you think I have yeah
like over 100 hours an elephant right
yeah you know what I mean so the devil
Elder ring now complete you just beat
God of War Ragnarok
what you got man you you are the person
to ask I think
I think it's gonna it is gonna be close
uh but I do I would say 60 40 elderly so
but I wouldn't be surprised here's my
thing like let's go I'm not mad if
either one wins I feel like both games
are the game of the year deserving I
just I'm concerned because Eldon ring
came out so long ago and uh recency I
think that because it's hard to like
remember how you felt when you played
Elder ring at the beginning of the year
when you literally are voting two or
three weeks after you play God of War so
that's the only thing I'm concerned
about but I do think Eldon ring is the
overall better game but not by much God
of War is a very uh appealing game and I
would not be surprised that God of War
snatches it part of me wants Elden ring
to win just so I could see uh the
PlayStation fan Boys on Twitter so what
is it about Elder ring that gives it the
edge to you what is it that puts it over
the heart I think it's the freedom
people love that freedom you know when
you give people uh deal and I do think
they're to a point there is the illusion
of Freedom right because most the places
you're going over and you're gonna get
clapped but um I I do think that just
because you can go to those areas and
you know maybe get you uh certain
aspects of the game that you wouldn't
normally have access to like God of War
you you have a little bit of freedom but
uh Elder Marine you can start that game
you can play exactly how you want to
play uh got a word you have different
variety of fighting styles but for the
most part you're going to use one of the
uh I almost suppose yeah
uh so you know
it's got replayability and I'm not
saying God of War does it but I do feel
like I beat God of War I beat a lot of
the in-game bosses and I feel like I'm
I'm done like I don't know if I'll go
back to it so Elden ring I I went I
played as a mage I'm like man I wonder I
wonder what's gonna be like playing as
this character I played that like five
times
replayability it's it's a lot of
replayability but God of War that
narrative and and focus is hard to beat
because they did it very well there's a
lot of different incidences in God of
War why I was hyped and I felt that an
Eldon ring but a different degree and
I'm just curious to find out how the
people are actually voting is going to
do it now my last question before we
move is the thing that some most people
feel baby God of War really could
challenge his narrative and one of the
say nitpicks of Elder ring is that maybe
the narrative isn't the strongest so
like do you the narrative okay
The Narrative is strong in Elden ring
it's just not told like God of Wars
narrative is told and I think that God
of War's narrative has taught a lot more
to uh to a broader audience because
Eldon ring is there it's just you got to
go look for it you know uh and I know
relatively the the the aspects to the
Elden ring it's you know
and Elden ring it's really about uh What
uh man I already forgot her name it's
like the little witch like she's the
center of all of Elden ring like pretty
much everything is going on because of
her God of War they tell you the story
as it's going on and Eldon ring like a
lot of the key components that happen in
Elder ring happened before the game even
took place okay and that is where a lot
of the narrative is Rana yeah right so
it's just like look
I think it could go either way I do I
honestly do think it goes okay last
question shout out to do which I was
going to ask is he said he's not big on
these cinematic experience games they
sacrificed too much gameplay for the
cinematics do you feel that's the case
with Ragnarok in comparison to the on
the ring situation or is that old no
okay no I think that's overblown I think
that they gave you the game and the
features and how the game played exactly
how they intended it to play I think
that you could blend the hardware more
you can uh blame like the art Direction
and how how great the game looks because
Eldon rain looks good in a lot of
aspects and they were able to do a lot
of different things with what they have
and I'm convinced if it was just a PS5
game you would have gotten more
graphically demanding game than you did
but the problem is is they they can't
rebuild something when it was already
built on something else it was already
built on the PlayStation 4 and most
likely poured it over and enhanced on
the PlayStation 5 Dev kits so that
that's that's that's what the culprit is
it's not the direction in the in how the
graphics look who's the culprit it's the
PlayStation 4. they're holding them back
it's not a little bit this time
little man has been marked safe you know
how you do that on Facebook there's a
little man a little man free zone
who's afraid someone is boxing someone
did ask a question I think king would
like this question okay uh I just ended
the uh I ended the question but I
remember this one uh King when do you
think that that PC version of ragnarok's
coming out six months damn that's quick
shout out to her Herm said six months to
the Year this is how we do it I'm
actually with him a little bit I think
it it will come out like the end of next
year maybe a little bit more than six
months like nine but I think it'll be
out next year for some reason I have a I
think if anyone Game of the Year this
year he's gonna win it next year
yo 589 in the chat man we having some
fun hit that like button man let me see
when you come to the house you having
some fun you know it's a good discussion
out exactly tell a friend tell a friend
just get somebody in this DLC yo you
stupid so like shut up I'll be obviously
the rest of us you know have the full
picture that attic has but just initial
feel what's the feel like so I'm like
what is it look at what this game of the
year situation how's it feeling to solve
it feels like it's gonna be a whole lot
of 2018 energy again but I think it's
going to be in Reverse this time
you're doing that
I think they're going to try to give as
many other Awards to God Awards possible
and they're gonna give game of the year
to Eldon rank you know it would be crazy
to happen in 2018.
I can't let them get off that with that
time also what travesty happened in 2018
song
my game ran rough shot through all the
awards the game of the year they were
like oh but Corey Ballard
[Applause]
I do want to point that out how do you
realistically win every award but not
Game of the Year not game of the year
but
what happens if Eldon ring sweeps the
whole rewards
and it could happen it could happen as
well and that would be I would think
that's just as well um but to be honest
like 100 like I think it's Elden ring
because what addict pointed out I think
Elden ring
they took a formula that is Niche a
niche formula where that has its
supporters it has a big crowd of people
that love those games but it is very uh
it had always been a niche thing not
even bloodborne that people love or
whatever that it was a PS exclusive PS4
exclusive not even that could bring more
people and it was more action oriented
right it was very more it was much more
action oriented
um not even that could bring the amount
of people that Elden ring brought in for
the simple fact that they turn those
games into an open World sandbox
essentially and and told you okay if you
go this direction you might get wiped
but if you go the other direction maybe
you won't maybe you maybe you can grind
a little bit and get good back to or you
can die in both directions
but either way the choice and the
openness of you to be able to be like
okay because if you play Dark Souls if
reach a certain point and you can't get
past it tough yeah you get good get good
go back and grind go back and grind and
it does give you that right gives you
the ability to grind and just kind of
brute force your way through certain
things at a certain point even if you
don't have the skill to be that you may
be powerful enough to beat something but
it there's a level of grinding there
that is just repeating the same things
over and over again whereas Elden ring
allows you to con to do that but kind of
go wherever you want and figure out what
you want to fight and then the thing
about elderly is that world
bro you you will find stuff in that
world you're like what the hell like you
know when I heard about like an
underworld a complete different
underworld that existed like it the map
just kept opening up exactly just
opening up and to me that's where I when
I think about next-gen gameplay and the
things I want to see I've always talked
about I want more density in my games I
want the AI to be crazy I want the
worlds to be truly explorable right
to me Elden ring did that and it did it
in a way that again brought in people
that never in their life would think
about playing this type of game was
playing Souls games
don't don't take my joint don't leave me
there I do feel just real quick I do
feel like
social media presence and YouTube
presence yeah it was way bigger and
elderly it was to the point where I had
big YouTubers like if you ain't gonna
make an elder ring video don't even make
a video they bullied me into playing the
game I wasn't even going to play I was
like that I'm good I know I what I like
and whatever he's like nah nah we gotta
see you got to see like I was I was like
Dad like people love this game so much
that by insistence to stay out of it
what's bothering them that they had to
give me it but I just had to try to
finish up I'm sorry so I mean to me it's
Elder ring but to be honest I'm I'm
gonna be messy oh if something like
vampire survivors win I would laugh my
ass you gonna laugh you gonna like
you're gonna like the final question
about this because when you talk about
gaming just gaming the pure sort of
dopamine hit of like one more one more
one more that's the epitome of that
right I understand addict doesn't like
it for his reasons and that's totally
valid yeah but to me something like that
small to win because of what it
represents as a pure gaming thing I'm
gonna be pissed at that wins
I'd rather have Tetris 4D win that oh
yeah but but yeah I to me if you're
picking between these two it's Elder
ring I think Eldon removed things
forward in a way that gets God of War
just gave you more of the same and again
and I'm not taken away from that that
game is a the ex the perfect example of
what you do when you polish something
yes to the feedback yes and they listen
to the feedback because oh that's one
thing we didn't say right we didn't say
yes I saw one troll in this game and the
troll got killed in his cutscene and I
haven't seen another troll since that
was addict's greatest argument you know
what I'm saying and now I did a really
good job on it they did a good job they
did a good job yeah so um yeah again God
of War is great I don't think if it gets
game of the year it to me is going to be
disappointing
it you got to step back and look at how
media perceives things we've recently
it's just not even recently not even
recently biased because I think Elden
ring was just such a big Zeitgeist thing
it's hard to forget that right even if
it wasn't February January whenever it
was
um
I just think like
no it wasn't March it was March March
there you go so it just feels like it
just feels like if you
you have to be willing to criticize the
things that you really love what are you
doing
oh I can't turn this camera off okay all
right here we go here we go
I just think there's an unwillingness to
be super super critical yeah shout out
to the IGN in Korea um
there's an unwillingness to be super
critical of things that have like
you know you look at God of War you like
this game is perfect like it's it's it's
it's polished there's nothing wrong with
it no bugs none of this or the other and
people immediately equate that with
perfection or Masterpiece and that those
things are those things can be mutually
exclusive you know what I mean like so I
just don't like a lot of like oh my God
it's the greatest thing I've ever seen
and done it's like come on like it's
fantastic don't get me wrong but let's
let's if the job is to criticize yeah
then your job is to nitpick and and and
pick at it
how do you feel about Jeff Healey coming
out there and saying
[ __ ] and I was talking about like come
on bro like yeah you have a platform
that's supposed to and he the first
thing he's gonna say is I have nothing
to do with that
that's hard too oh kind of Striker came
at you so he said you're the biggest
contrarian
it's not about that why am I why am I
going to agree with just what everyone
else says for the sake of a dream
definition
but this is the thing I'm not be if I
say oh I just don't like it because
that's one thing I give you receipts for
everything and all of it is legitimate I
don't I'm not being unfair to this game
at all I'm telling you I don't want to
do anything but play this game okay
people just get mad that I'm not like oh
I'm on my knees for this game
because you don't like it like they do
yeah
yeah you know it's just like just
emotionality a little bit of
emotionality a little bit of
emotionality listen and and I I'm a big
fraud because when it comes to Reddit
but uh yeah we talked about this game of
the year
they have to stop the cap
the money went in already
everybody went in already but he went in
for what sir we we paid the necessary
yeah oh it's been a bag a bag has been
dropped the bag has been dropped
obviously you did can see the review
it's it's the second coming of uh god
father are you implying that the review
that that the the older is applying
nothing Don't You Buck up on me
it must have been soon don't have to be
told wait a minute wait a minute we're
shooting what you mean we are stupid
come on man the writing's on the wall
put it out right before it was time did
we make the cut Mr keighley oh my Lord
do you like the kid package we sent you
so are you implying
all right so basically what you apply
November 3rd Jeff Keely put out a tweet
um God of War Ragnarok is a towering
achievement
[Laughter]
for richer more expensive than it's 2018
predecessor it took me 30 hours to
complete and it's filled with many
surprises I won't spoil truly incredible
what this team achieved through covet
this is why we play games so that he had
to continue on with his threats wrote
exactly what he was supposed to do it
uh
check cleared man it's good
I hope he got the new controller we sent
him
[Laughter]
a new controller with the DLC and we
also send them a reminder for what he
did for us in the past what did he do
for you to pass her don't forget the
last time
hit the button just like you did oh okay
so this is
the check cleared everything good okay
great okay
I just feel anyway regardless to what
I honestly feel that though the ring is
a second to none oh and the reason why I
feel Elden ring is second to none just
like God of War 2018 there to change the
formula that's what that's what gives
you that over the edge of uh that you
need
if it was just like Demon Souls
it would have just been same as and
people would have been like
good Souls game if it was bloodborne 2
and it followed the same exact pattern
as bloodborne one it'd have been like a
good uh you know bloodborne game you
know
Elder ring changed it up so much
when I had solved and I was like yo I'm
picking up Elder ring uh oh you got to
gift it to me whatever whatever he was
like you ain't playing that because a
second though put me off of those games
but this game wasn't like sekiro
this game wasn't like any Souls games
that came before it this game said here
you go King play how you want to play
you want to do it this way you want to
struggle in this world but this reward
for your struggle
it was so much reward for my struggle my
whole impetus in even getting the game
my whole Drive was to invade somebody's
world to show up as that little red guy
and invade somebody's world and do evil
things to them because when you see a
dude pop up in your world red you like
what's that
it's a dude coming through the mountains
and he was like yeah read this what it
said I can't read that what is that it
says it's blurry as hell
um a bit definitely a bears repeating I
do not select the nominees we have a
jury of over 100 Global media Outlets
that make those selections Buck yeah
I hope it's a great time yo I'm doubling
Flames out of pocket the thing of the
matter is anytime you got to come out
and defend your platform we already know
if if Kojima is there we already know
where it's going right so we we already
know your pattern saying you don't came
out vocally
you shouldn't have I mean there's always
if God award does win they're gonna look
right at you they're gonna look right at
your Tweet and they're gonna look at
your platform and they're going to say
that it's a bias there just like the CMA
do coming out saying we want to keep my
PlayStation on my PlayStation come on
man there's certain things you can't do
and can't say if you were in this realm
but it's okay I just feel Elden ring
took it A step above and beyond God of
War and I'm not taking nothing away from
God of War yeah God of War DLC came out
it was exactly what I expected it to be
a little bit more refinement here a
little bit more polish here not too much
over the top hair not too much below
here
just a a good continuation to a story
that I wanted to finish notice that I
keep saying story right right because
I'm gonna keep saying story because 90
90 of the time you're listening and
watching the story opposed to actually
getting in there doing some gameplay
beat this area right here even in the
middle of a fight it'll break into a cut
scene yeah just to let them explain that
one part of the fight and they go right
back into the next fight right so it's a
formula that he's using for me
Elder ring kept my attention
from the Alchemy aspect of it from the
combat aspect of it of what would I do
if I just wipe my character and start it
over and was this character how would
that uh handle it was just so many
different things that I went to sleep
and I woke up thinking I could do this
different I can fight this different and
attic knows your attic would be like
where you at oh I'm fighting this Dragon
oh you need some help yeah and he jumped
in the world that's a different added
layer to the game so for me Elder ring
had more of something that I wasn't used
to it was more generational more
genre refining oh and and and and
breaking the mold opposed to this game
this game is more of the same very good
polish more of the same but Elder ring
just broke the mold and it's going to be
very different going forward from that
company
oh look it's gonna be a good battle this
is gonna be a good battle I didn't think
to be honest I didn't think God of War
would really have a chance initially so
I saw what elderly did man there's no
everything y'all saying is no question
the the change of the formula opened it
up to the masses you know the the sheer
amount of complexity and gameplay the
boss fights the difficulty the what's
next Over the Horizon you know what I'm
saying and then trying to handle it I
thought was fantastic you know look I'm
not a sales guy but that game really
it's it's it's as far as gameplay design
is the next one and the fact that it
didn't hold your hand
the fact that it really there was it
trusted the player to say you figure it
out most games is like yo go here do
this Quest log all of this the tropes of
gaming and it was a bold design choice
to say no no no we're not doing that so
I gotta give it to that
but you guys know how I feel about souls
and it's like I get it it's just I know
what's for me it was not for me and I I
have to admit yeah God of War stuff the
hashtag just was stuff is just for it's
for me and and I like narrative based
games I've always always loved that I
love I think games are the greatest
entertainment next to movies if not
Superior movies because you can actually
play it in Iraq
yeah so to me you know and then
obviously
your daughter
the epicness of of Kratos the character
you know I love storytelling I love I
love those moments when I put the
controller down for a little bit and
listen to what's about to go on and go
back into it yes is it a Vic qtf e heavy
yes you know what I'm saying is it more
sometimes cinematic to gameplay I get
that that's that's legit criticism I
don't have anything with that I just
like that the scale of it I just like
that
I feel like if someone's watching it
that's not into gaming yeah and they
look at that that that's gonna resonate
what's happening the right like what's
happening here and then obviously the
gods I'm biased let's just call it what
it I am biased to mythology the gods and
that's my thing so I'm a little happy
that God was Ragnarok is in the
conversation because to be honest I
didn't even think anything was going to
come close to the challenge so yeah
it'll be interesting you know what I'm
saying my personal pick obviously I play
both but I haven't finished either so
you know right now I'm leaning God which
is how I feel we're gonna say Ragnarok
right now I just feel it it feels epic
it feels what I'm doing is something
special but anyone who says Elder ring
is superior I can't really push back too
hard on it it's it's what you prefer the
thing I have for y'all solve a little
bit too early
is there any chance
anything other than these two games
could win game of the year
I have to ask you all this
I mean
Requiem
maybe narrative like if people really do
like The Narrative of God of War Requiem
and like I said the the super out of
left field tiny game that you know
people been talking about since the
beginning of the year
um you just never know right you just
never know because it you know it's the
gaming press so it it the gaming press
when it comes to the recently buyer
stuff I don't really think that that buy
I don't buy that as much with the Press
because the Press has been you know
they've been reviewing games all year
they know what the Zeitgeist moments
were I you know I think I I would think
more that a fan would be swayed by
recency bias than than the uh the Press
per se
um so yeah I think that you know
if there's anything out of left field it
could be Requiem or or
vampire survivors beyond that no I don't
think any people would really like
playing tail records so I put I asked
another question I like this q a feature
what other games do you guys consider
could win games of the year
and then my personal is would be Seafood
I think Seafood
when it comes to cinematic combat and
the way they handle it in that game
there's no other game that feels like a
kung fu movie
that in that way
um yeah they did some special stuff I'll
get a chance to try that today and I
will say
um even though it's not Game of the Year
probably
but I got I know people killing that yo
grounded came out of nowhere for me bro
like I really like grounding like I love
that game now I know it's not giving him
I just wanted to get a nomination for
something the reason why I can't say
that right and I believe that it's and
this is what hurts that game talk to me
the fact that it was in uh pre-alpha
beta boy in my joint yeah
that's okay
it it takes away from the title
because the the title is being curated
in the background and everybody's help
developing this game and giving feedback
and everything so you really pull away
the layers of newness to it okay and
release so for a person that never
played it and got a chance to play it
for them that's gonna probably be that
game of the year because that game is so
addictive in its nature and how you play
it but us
it won't reach that because you have to
say you have to go back to I think was
like two years ago that game was uh for
me though right now I hear what you're
saying for me I actually took your
approach when that thing came out I
touched it once I'm like nope I won't
touch it no more I'll wait until it's
finished but I understand I understand
your overall point I get what you're
going with that now that's this I just
wouldn't addict any uh any any other
thing got a shot tries
um heavyweight match up
I can't really think of any to be honest
with you uh maybe Splatoon if they give
that like that Nintendo thing um I don't
think Mario rabbits would uh appeal to
as many people that would be necessary
they'll probably get like strategy
probably be nominated for that I'll go
ahead and read uh some of the the
questions someone said maybe ependama is
able to make the cut off I don't I think
Putnam is all out of the cutoff I don't
think he is it can be some available
yeah Summerville pentiment I don't know
if that make it yeah I mean nominations
already tomorrow so oh yeah it's wrapped
in okay ironically it is funny right it
is extended long enough for God of War
to be here
it is kind of interesting that the
nominations is the week after God award
yeah some sounds like a bag
could you please hold that up I won't
get ready until next week
and then someone else said a plateau
yeah we said that we mentioned it uh and
then someone it's a triangle strategy
um triangle strategy is a good game and
I actually reviewed it it's on the
channel if you guys want to watch that
um but I don't think it's going to it's
too vague like it's not it's not shiny
and a lot of that time you have to be
shiny to actually win again
look anyway
we move our horses if everybody's done
with their uh heavy weight down a second
oh and then that's just to point out
that once again Horizon is buried under
the Horizon bro yeah
I have a feeling it'll get nominated yo
what happens if Horizon and God of War
is nominated and Elden ring just
snatches it from us it's gonna be
interesting anything can happen I will
say that this is one of them I don't
know we got to see how it's gonna play
no Horizon so
here here's the result of the poll what
is winning game of the year Eldon ring
or God of War 76 set out in ring and 24
said God of War and 406 people
um they participated
I don't like the pool yeah
408 votes next week's gonna be
interesting no doubt oh yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
No Doubt then we got Mr Nichols two
dollar Super Chat remember Splatoon
Nintendo Game of the Year oh this was
told Nintendo in the gang okay switch
game coming in hot chat then we got
Spartan goes 17 two pounds Super Chat
Elden ring narrative is sold separately
yo
sold separately
pause right there we got a tiger sorry
this three dollar Super Chat what's this
uh Elder ring a God of War not Ragnarok
nonsense sifu is easy game of the year
that's right feel that way
the doctor 63 five dollars even though I
loved it I got bullied into playing
elderly facts
had everything except an actual story
wow
the table is blocking my full view but I
believe what I'm seeing below the lower
half of the table are the legs of Jeff
kneeling down and above the upper half
of the table I see Jim Ryan wow
oh my God so we got Mandingo big
thickets once again two dollar Super
Chat game of the year out of left field
straight okay okay straight nomination
in the building
[Laughter]
we have uh epic Troy two dollars of
attack disrespect for Bayonetta three is
unreal
okay there's too much surrounding that
game man yeah it's gay coming in hot
then we got hargit to knee five dollars
to protect Summerville is coming out in
a couple of days and the pedigree of the
developers may put it in the Game of the
Year discussion as well
for the game awards but they're they're
all and we didn't even say tunic too
yeah uh Halo infinite is my game of the
year okay okay all right that's bold
and we got mine
and I love it no fix your face what is
it
Halo infinite's been out is this thing
you came with you that it can be up no
it can't it was it last year I remember
it missed it
oh no that's right that's right oh yo
Halo Infinity is in the mix yeah
I have the narratives changed
maybe they get multi
I don't know oh Call of Duty yeah
buddy we'll be playing a community meet
with you guys soon
someone said the disrespect for
Bayonetta three is unreal yeah
giving us all a business and finally we
got Bonza rally games I remember for 18
months while I'm enjoying Ragnarok about
eight hours in so far I'm Elden ring and
Elder ring is Far and Away the better
game so far too many puzzles not enough
combat yeah okay shout out the fuzzy
play these games he do what he do
yep we're good all right shout out to
Anchorman V in the business
the most deadliest man in America yes
yes uh he took an Airbnb in the wildest
neighborhood ever yeah
Compton right so we we took an Uber out
there shout out to him for taking
getting my bag he got my bag right and
took him back to his place and then we
took an Uber over to him you know this
place is so hood that when we called the
Uber the same exact car that dropped me
off
I said no we can't do this I was I was
scared for his safety sir yo salute that
was some great days man salute to B
buddy rest in peace cow yes because
those are some times my first kind of
e3s out there Anchorman V mic check real
quick make sure your levels is good
we'll see how you sounded uh dude okay
you guys hear me okay yeah yeah no doubt
so we got you on this topic as well but
I think so is this Saturday let me read
yeah okay let me read this last slide
Dorian Gray five dollars Super Chat I
love the irony is in order to be game of
the year you have to be as far from a
game as possible wow is this sad that
anchorback kind of sounds better than we
did last week yeah
anyway so look let's get into a song
this is your topic right what's going on
with uh do maternal and conscious what's
happening
all right so this all started in 2020.
back when do maternal launched uh there
were issues that fans had with the um
first of all the um the soundtrack to
the game was supposed to launch with the
special edition and it did not right
um when it finally did launch it
launched in poor condition where the mix
is on the official soundtrack were
inferior and different to what was
actually in the game
um
so the conversation around this
basically came down to uh Marty Stratton
over from uh Bethesda I
basically he went on Reddit blaming
Mick Gordon the composer for not meeting
deadlines and and kind of blaming him
completely for why the the
um the soundtrack was not available when
the special edition launched and for the
overall quality of the soundtrack
um
and so fast forward two years later Mick
Gordon answers it I don't know if he was
under some sort of NDA to not speak but
basically end ensuing two years that
those damning statements about MC Gordon
have kind of affected his career
um so just recently MC Gordon came out
and kind of laid the record straight
with a lot of receipts I mean that was
you could say this was a bibliography
like this was a very lengthy post right
um indicating that
um talking about the working conditions
that he worked under the fact that a
vast majority of the things that he
submitted for the uh that for for the
soundtrack were uh not approved for one
reason or the other
um he basically indicated that the
entire working uh situation with Marty
Stratton was not good for him and you
know that he tried his best within what
he was able to do to put out the product
that he you know that he was supposed to
and they would just they were just uh
things that were impeding him along the
way specifically Marty Stratton and the
way he sort of ran things and and and
sort of what it would make Gordon
indicated was like basically abusive
behavior
um so in his post he goes on to say that
he was essentially not paid for 11
months because of uh because again he
had not met according to Marty Stratton
deliverables and um in addition to that
when the final sort of version of the
soundtrack came out what was found is
that they used a lot of the stuff that
he had submitted that was rejected
so they still use that stuff and again
did not pay him or or give him the
proper credit for that so
um yeah this is just recently that he
came out and sort of set the record
straight on this and again with the
amount of receipts that he came out with
um it it's pretty damning from Marty
Stratton and and the team over there and
his face is killing me
so he's ready to burst I know he's ready
to burst on this so
uh what do you guys think again a lot of
we've seen a lot of this stuff happen
where these fights are ensue sort of in
so in social media and then it's left to
the public to it's stuff that maybe the
public would never even be privy to
um is out there now and then you use the
sort of court of public opinion to sway
opinion one way or another
um and but I think you know in this case
it just feels like Mick Gordon feels
that his career has been negatively
affected enough where it's fair that he
comes out and says the things that he
says and kind of sets the record
straight because again initially the
statement that was supposed to come out
two years ago was supposed to be a joint
statement between them about you know
kind of the corporate Hey listen I feel
this way you feel that way let's just
come out together and try to squash this
right uh with a settlement
professionally with a settlement right
with a settlement and professionally so
that both of us come out of this as
clean as possible and we can move
forward with our careers we agree to
disagree on certain things and we agree
that we're not going to work together
anymore but let's let's let's not bury
each other here right and what happened
was that what what Gordon thought was
going to be a joint statement just
turned out to Marty Stratton putting out
this statement solo on Reddit that again
had a basically had a life of its own
after that and put
um MC Gordon in a very negative light so
again two years later I don't know if
it's an NDA thing or if he just felt
like you know he wanted to get his
receipts together whatever the case may
be he comes out with all of this so uh
what do you guys think because this is
ugly I want to set up Aiken the reason
why I I could be a v here obviously uh
you know very close to situation with
all things Bethesda and all things
Bethesda and another thing I want to is
that um you know I try to be try to be
as balanced as possible obviously
there's a lot of out uproar about this
and a lot of people we we could I think
it's fair to say that um Mick has gained
a lot of public support since he
responded and you see a lot of famous
people kind of getting but I wanted to
kind of get the other side as well in
the full picture because I think about
has additional context here so hey man
once this news broke out you know what
are you feeling about this entire
situation between ID software
um what is it Marty Stratton and uh Mick
Gordon the actual composer from The Duel
so I actually remember back in May of
2020 reading Marty stratton's post and I
remember just being like
okay sounds like independent contractor
an artist can't meet deadlines I'm
surprised not at all so
um but then reading this
part of the problem with the reason why
I can't just outright believe it is
because this thing didn't come out like
a month in ago because
if the hell and the Taylor thing never
happened I would believe him
situations has you questioning things
now
because I mean I got burned for
believing her before and so now now I
have to be like okay where's the burden
of proof yeah and as Saab said
that he showed receipts
I actually Dell like delved into the
receipts and they are actually don't
prove anything which is really sad
interesting
um because I before I even started
reading this like what 10 page essay
about like all this stuff same heavy
receipt baby like heavy I read yeah I
read the original I read Marty's post
again and then I read his entire thing
and then I read Marty's post again and
oddly enough the timelines add up uh
there's like maybe one or two
questionable things but the one key
factor is that Marty's definitely engage
that corpo speaks uh spectral ability
where he is intentionally vague in
certain aspects and I actually compiled
like an actual timeline in terms of what
actually happened
um and I'll I'll try to Breeze over as
much as I can but just to give with some
context to some stuff because it's
like I said all this stuff does add up
it does fit the same timeline
um so I just put it in pure
chronological order okay uh so
originally mix started working with
Bethesda back in 2015 and he actually
cites this as a reason why uh so I don't
know which game it was but he claims
that he worked for Bethesda on a project
without getting a contract to do the OST
and I'm pretty sure it's Wolfenstein
okay
um someone else mentioned it could be
prey but I
I don't know he worked on something so
yeah but worked on something but
Bethesda didn't end up using it and they
just kind of scrapped his OST that he
created okay um and he never got paid
for it right
so going forward uh this is something he
mentions at one point he says so he
began working on Doom Eternal in 2017
um they had delays getting his contract
he was like two weeks behind they set up
the schedule that was very idealistic
um he voices concerns to Marty and
Marty's like no this is actually a very
attainable schedule right and they they
hit the they hit the ground already with
a disagreement there right they started
behind
um let's see so he and I also cut out
like a lot of the stuff like oh I didn't
feel like I was a part of the team he
was a 1099 contractor he's not really a
good employee from Bethesda so yeah
you're not going to feel the same kind
of level there
um but then uh the first real point of
contention is that quakecon 2018
um Bethesda eternally teased Doom
Eternal and they use some of his music
uh that that later after the event they
later Bethesda rejected or specifically
its software rejected right and they
tried not to pay him for it but then he
also like fired back saying hey uh
actually you did use this so it is
technically approved you need to pay me
for it so in January 2019 they paid him
but after that point they stopped
accepting any other work
and they did not pay him for 11 months
at that point right there's another
point of contention so and and but
really that's kind of normal uh
especially at a task completion Market
where it's like hey you're trying to do
X Y and Z you want to finish this
project you actually have to have this
approvals before you get paid so it's
not
abnormal kind of shitty but not abnormal
um so kind of forwarding through here
let's see what was the the first major
part so Marty had said uh at E3 2019
that's they announced the soundtrack for
The collector's edition which he says
yeah
and that was with the November 19th
sorry November of 2019 release date
before they delayed it right
um
the pre-order page and this is one of
the points that he uses as a receipt and
say they promised that Mick Gordon was
going to uh do the OST right it says
let's actually saved the picture
he showed the actual wording says
a playable cassette tape plus download
codes for lossless digital copies of
Mick Gordon's Doom 2016
and doom eternal's original soundtrack
they do not claim Mick Gordon was doing
the Doom eternal's original soundtrack
hmm
so I I have a theory they didn't want to
get him to do it after the events of the
game's production yep well he this is
the big point of contention because he's
claiming that they put his they
announced they were going to make this
soundtrack and they put his name on it
without his knowledge of it and he felt
pressured because of that that's his
that's where he's fighting but this is
where reading comprehension and grammar
comes into play so
so wait so you're saying that your shows
it only says Mick Gordon's Doom 2016
soundtrack and doom eternal's original
soundtrack
they do not say Mick Gordon's doomed
Eternal soundtrack he has a receipt he
just says
I'm gonna tell you what his receipts
ain't that it's saying the Doom um
collector's edition this is announced at
June but that's the Showcase June 6
2019. he claims that he says um that it
tells you all the things they're going
to give you the skin it is a full-size
Slayer helmet and this is a playable
cassette tape plus download codes for
lost lists digital copies of Mick
Gordon's Doom 2016 and doom so they he
got a picture to say his name on it and
Doom's Eternal but Doom 2016
specifically yes yes yes Doom 16 yeah it
does say 20 in the analysis and dual
maternals original soundtracks so Mick
Gordon is doing 2016. yeah right I see
what you say so you say they didn't say
it's very intentional wording okay so I
think that they didn't plan to have him
come back for the original soundtrack oh
okay okay all right and that fits in
with what Marty was saying by saying
that oh well uh we didn't want to put
that on his play so they're trying to
say we really didn't intend to ever have
him do it gotcha but he because then he
started inquiring got it okay it's
illegal about it hey wait a minute I'm
supposed to be doing this and I don't
think they ever intended for him to do
it okay and that's why Marty was just
kind of iffy about it and go hesitant
about it because he didn't want to do it
at all okay and that's when you started
hearing about Chad
Chad I got to read this account Chad
getting all the smoke Chad is the guy
that I guess was helping out but yeah
for oh through the music while I guess
big wasn't there or whatever so and
suppose and according to the metadata
which uh Nick points out which was kind
of different data says he started August
of 2019 and if they had a release date
for November of 2019 that's about you
know three months three solid months to
work on it right
and so that's enough time for him to do
it but
uh so that fits at least in the timeline
so then October 2019 they have the delay
they go to March 2020.
um then November 2019 he gets paid for
his entire work on the game uh so it's
not like he hadn't been paid for his
work uh but the the real iffy part comes
in afterwards right uh after the after
the game actually comes out or really it
really started January 20 uh 2020 they
say that January 8th Mick um
uh so this is what Marty said he said
after discussions with making January of
this year we reached General agreement
on the terms for for Mick to deliver the
OST by early March uh so according to
Mick January 8th Mick had uh emailed
Bethesda since uh Marty was M.I.A on
this he couldn't find him for to USD but
that's agreed to pay him for the 29th to
the 2015 OST that he did that they
didn't use because they started selling
it right uh the end of 2019 so they
agreed to pay him for that but they're
limping in with the soundtrack so
Mick claims that Marty lied about it and
said oh when his Reddit post he said we
signed the contract no they said they
reached a general agreement
in January okay so that's what I'm
pointing at his receipts don't really
add up
um that's a damn he claims one thing but
the actual post doesn't say that okay if
you read it in terms of corpo speak it's
very technical
um
and it's not a lie burp
so but yeah then they go back and forth
about what the original deal was like
Marty says oh they agreed on doing 12 uh
and then Mick said oh well I said
originally I was gonna do 30 and then we
backed it down to 12. right it's like it
just back and forth he said she said
after that at that point right um yeah
it's okay so just just to be clear also
this is
prior most of this stuff originated
prior to acquisition
yes and that that's the that's actually
the point where I think he quit so the
the main thing was after the release uh
he actually only completed 10 of the 12
tracks right
um according by mixone and Mission he
only did 10.
uh so they deliver the OST the hero
complaining Mick contacts him say hey we
need to fix this we need to have a
public statement
um
Mick says sure but then Marty makes the
post so that pisses them off right and
then they go to attorneys
though let's get to the spice let's go
so the actual timeline of the attorneys
going back and forth is that so late
April uh Marty and Mick have the call
right Marty makes the post in May Mick
brings his lawyers in he's the one who
instigated it
um and say hey we need to fix this
Cinemax initially refuses
and then Mick counters them saying that
oh Marty heard His Image he was
underpaid Marty contradicted the Public
Announcement
um
and so Cinemax offered a settlement
so they pay him all they agree to pay
him all the money that he's owed right
in that on the condition that Mick fixes
the Doom Eternal soundtrack right
uh Mick agrees to this only if Marty
takes down the post the post is the
point of contention this Reddit post
that Marty put up basically explaining
the contentious relationship and that
they will be moving forward without Mick
for for the for the music and to your
point just to reiterate the they were
close to subtle but the point of
contention from Mick standpoint is I
need the post taken down
yep okay and so which Cinemax rejected
it and so the offer was rescinded right
so then xenomax uh so Mick comes back
it's almost at the back yeah I just need
y'all to take that down and just like my
man cradle you know what's crazy
about the fact the fact that something
so small is taking down a post would
prevent Cinemac from closing that
lawsuit down like yeah it's interesting
is that according to Mick he said that
he wasn't getting any response from
Marty until he went to cinema his
frustration from his standpoint is that
I kept trying to have this conversation
and then I just want to add additional
context because there is one point that
of course again for mixed contact which
is very long which is that he claims he
went to the actual Reddit post owner the
owner of the Reddit
and said look I am the guy that made the
music this guy is from it's her friend
is besmirching my name can you please
take it down he got them to take it down
when he went direct to the source but
then Dakota to him his voice of
frustration is that the post went back
up maybe like a week later because I
guess Marty was the one that put it
there so wait what I just want to add
the human element and then we're gonna
get back to the legal is that according
to Mick
because this soundtrack is not pieced
together very well for according you
know from this this the way it's
stitched together I guess it's not good
it's not to the standard that anybody
would like and that he is getting fan
harassment that he is being he's
claiming his reputation is is bespered
she's blackball fans are attacking him
to the point mentally it is affecting
him and and he's getting threat that's
where his standpoint I just want to be
fair to his standpoint but now let's get
back to the legal back to anger man
where you at but it was perfect timing
because uh that's actually the the split
there so as soon as uh they were send
that offer that's when he goes to Reddit
to see if he can get it down right it
doesn't work uh so then all of a sudden
it initially works I come back yes that
initially works but it doesn't solve me
do it right back up in the sky like like
the best signal no no no no no no no no
no
that was for one week
that's right and so then he goes back to
the table again and so xenomax says uh
he's like oh yeah just take down the
post uh I'll I'll do the OST that's it
Cinemax says Nope here's a six-figure
gag order shut the hell up and leave us
alone like but why are they taking it
why is it gag if if if it ain't wrong
why are they throwing money out here
okay well no I mean because like the
whole thing with Michael Jackson was
like oh he had a settlement for you know
for Ophelia but that's not in the
mission of guilt people to leave you
alone that's okay
uh so then Mick counters the refusal all
right because he counters the gag order
saying oh quote remove the Reddit post
pay me for the extra music and Duty
Turtle and I'll produce another version
of the OST right
um so Cinemax stalls on the order all
the way into 2021 right he waited and
then refuses and then says take the take
the hash money right and the post is
still standing then right yep and that
was in January and then the Microsoft
acquisition happens right let's get it
okay
and after that that's actually kind of
where his post ends there's nothing
really much after that he basically just
kind of says they didn't care anymore
yeah uh about him do you think he was
hoping that they were gonna come back
and be like oh yeah Microsoft you're
gonna you're gonna back me up right nah
right
that's before we got here we don't know
nothing about that
mad Cricket but according to Mick the
reason why he did all this because he
said that Marty lied about the
circumstances around the Doom Eternal
soundtrack and used disinformation and
innuendo to blame me entirely for its
failure afterwards Marty offered me a
six-figure settlement to never speak
about it as far as I'm concerned the
truth is more important he said the the
post all these posts
severely impacted both my professional
and personal reputation in releasing
this statement I'm exercising my right
to defend myself it is a defense not an
unprovoked attack he also goes on to
state that he issued with extreme
reluctance he was to do this after all
other attempts to resolve the battle had
failed and the last one he says or why
he did it is this statement is not an
excuse for a hate campaign acts of hate
dished out online won't result in any
positive change in fact it only makes
things work so he he's basically coming
out and saying look you know the this
the damage was done at this point he
can't take it because he feels that his
This Is A Lie against his name and this
is where we at yeah this is this is the
hot one so egg I know you finished up
the recap yeah what fraud alert wait
hold on okay what
take the money B take the money yeah
nah they lying and just run over to get
your cash that's all I can tell you why
I can tell you why he's doing this I
figured it out all right let me hear
your hypothesis I was talking with uh
our good friend Nicholas Downey
and he he brought a name to me and I
figured it out what you figured out so
this is uh prior to this this is Mick
Gordon's official resume of work okay
um his first thing was a Killer Instinct
that was the first big thing that people
would be like oh yeah I'll try because
he was doing like Need for Speed Shift
Marvel Superhero Squad a bunch of other
boards that don't really care don't do
that angry man's a legend don't do that
but prior to 2013 nobody cared about
this guy okay but he also worked on
Wolfenstein New Order
Blood Fire done but Doom 2016 is where
he suddenly came out yes oh wow this is
it yes he was getting a lot of work from
Bethesda yes
um and then pray 2017 one Mustang two
New Colossus get a lot of love yes
and then it's like a beautiful
desolation uh the Doom Eternal and then
after that nothing but atomic heart
coming out next year right but
here's the thing though you know who uh
picked up pieces after he left cool
Andrew holschult
um
he replaced him
he did the Doom Eternal ancient gods
by himself fine and so but people but
nobody mentioned anything nobody thought
like the music sucks but he was like no
he's great he's amazing now he's getting
that work over at Bethesda and I think
what it is ultimately is
Mick feels like he's replaceable like he
always was yeah
we know what side of the
arguments
my other thing too
I still have not seen Mick Gordon show
any emails from anybody else at Bethesda
just the emails he sent to Bethesda oh
so you said that
actual receipt okay it's just he said
she said all right so just to defend
your point uh because you you definitely
team Aid right now oh body Stratton says
at the end of his post that he said if
you read all this thank you for your
time and attention as for the immediate
future we're at the point of moving on
and won't be working with Mick on the
DLC we currently have in production as I
mentioned his music is incredible he's a
rare talent I hope he wins many awards
for his contribution to do maternal at
the end of the year I miss as
disappointed as anyone that we're at
this point but as we have said many
times before we will adapt to changing
circumstances and pursue the most unique
and talented artists in the industry and
I think this is what you're alluding to
with whom to collaborate which must be
the guy you talk about our team has
enjoyed this creative collaboration a
great deal and we know Mick will
continue to Delight fans for many years
and it's almost like he's going to light
fans but he ain't going to delightful
clearly yeah
it should have just ran and that's all
he should have did but now let's get
let's open it up to the Lord
where you at with this because according
obviously we see body statement from Ed
we said Mick we've got kind of like a
college very long a lot of receipts a
lot I highly recommend people recommend
it Vic said the damage is so to him that
he can't you know Let it go you know
kind of thing so where are you at with
this whole situation based on what you
hear so far I feel like if the damage
was so bad then maybe preparing it's
it's like it's like the Johnny Depp
thing Johnny Depp wanted his reputation
and back more than he wanted money from
losing those things so he can actually
make money but at the same time
Johnny Depp got the money to go to court
and and to do this long firm form thing
it's like dude it's it's like King loves
to say it's big big take little Bank
like you you didn't you don't have the
money to to fight Bethesda in court for
years like just take the money and see
what you can do to repay your reputation
besides that like I hate when people get
took one over on I do but at the end of
the day it's like you can only do so
much that you can financially back and
to me
he should have just took the money
okay no go ahead no no my question to
you is I get where y'all going but let's
just for just you know [ __ ] that was
Advocate morality morality a devil's
advocate okay let's just say this post
has been sitting there for like two
years or whatever it's been right it's
basically saying
this trash soundtrack is your fault
the reason why the quality of this thing
is because of you let's just call it
what it is right that's what this body
post has been up there for two years so
let's just say you trying to get a job
or you try to work with some Outsider
Bethesda and this is looming over you
and on top of that the feds is like yeah
you with the trash out you ruined
they're beautiful Majestic do return
because of you and your incompetence and
now you got The Scarlet Letter wherever
you go wherever you put in that
application you are the guy that's been
known to ruin this how do you deal with
that how I navigate that y'all
I find it hard to believe that one job
has ruined his entire career in that
industry like that I believe he's only
got atomic heart ever since that game
came out yeah well maybe there's a
reason he only got the topic or keeps
getting delayed I mean
are you implying that he's he's saying
his words
for the reasons get delayed but I feel
like and I'm not saying that he can't
get destroyed like in the industry off
of one job but most the time there's
merits of Truth in people talking to
each other on why people don't want to
work with you all right so get out
because yeah yeah out of pocket with
certain things but I have to defend the
man on it all right so what about what
he said because this is a lately relay I
I know it's it's a lot so I'm just kind
of paraphrase I I sat and read all of
this like I could be I read all of it
right
what about when the man said they came
to him with the plan for doing return on
the soundtrack right and they say King
they say you got to give us two tracks a
month right he go I fine I'll do the two
tracks y'all just sit down shot coming
out with the game all I'm saying is
show me your build
he literally says show me your but he
said cause I y'all want me to create
music I don't have a context of what the
levels are right I don't know what the
overall theme of the game is going to be
so I just got it in my head imagine how
hard I just but come on
track man I ain't finished my boss so
you don't know what the levels are what
if you you sit there if you make it a
good food level you in your mind you
make something really body told or
whatever whatever and you don't got no
reference point so Doom is you in hell
you in space hell with a gun it has
always been space hell yeah
the context is like he would need to
know the layouts of uh
but here's the thing you wouldn't need
another lie to the level to properly do
his job but that's where he should have
went
I ain't doing it like he he shouldn't
decided and as a 1099 worker he knew
that he was not gonna say that anger man
nobody know that he's gonna take the job
I would have been here I will say I
would have been Mick there he does need
to know a little bit yeah
thank you so he was like gun space heavy
rock music go go to it no it's not that
simple
now come on man like
anchor come on come on man okay so so I
need two tracks from you by Friday yeah
get go ahead anchor bring me two two
Doom tracks about Friday
he I need to see what I'm doing
especially since Doom return is supposed
to be this this evolution of Doom 2016.
I need more some Concepts
not even contact they didn't give them
Concepts to show himself you know what's
bad about it he was trying to be ahead
of it he's like I know how y'all work
all right before y'all don't got the
greatest traffic
I think the problem is it's like I'm
with the dude but I feel like he should
have protected himself legally more than
he's not ask where I went anchor stop
doing stuff without no contract bro
that's how he Rock
and I will say Elise on his level at a
certain point like if it was this early
on in development because it was
supposed to it started development in
2017 January that's what he signed the
contract so the only thing about it is
like yo after a certain period of time
you're put as attorney contract you're
putting your own money into stuff and
you need that to pay off and so you're
just stuck with your situation yeah like
if you saw the first two to three months
like hey this is not gonna work out you
should have pulled out but at a certain
point it's like if we're talking like
four months or longer it's like yeah I I
have no option I put my own money into
this right right if I back out now I
don't get paid right so no for you and
at that point he should have did a
better job you know I mean we we small
fry them we talk to lawyers so how how
does he not do that you know what I'm
saying he knew him and he's like nah I'm
making gonna do me like this
and Marty we good on that yeah
maybe it is one of those things that he
had a lot of faith in that dude and that
Faith was not placed right it's just
like look like anyone if you're doing
anything in the business World lawyer
have them look it up put everything in
words don't believe anything anybody
says oh
take the six figure when he sent it to
you and just go ahead it's like you know
but I haven't seen the six figures
though the six he's telling you to shut
up right and you still have to hold you
gotta hold everybody everybody worse
cause right now he ain't got he just got
the L
but how much do you think he's making
for an OST like he would be making for
noise I don't know I hope it's more than
the voice acting so so the question is
the song though is there Europe is there
a six-figure number that song gonna shut
up is it a low six-figure yeah it just
says six right here
but it sounds like that Helena Taylor
like oh they offered me four thousand
dollars and it's like yeah to start per
session
no he came out was like they offered me
there's no scenario yeah all I should
have did what this man's did he he she
came out there with like some missing
pieces on on on like a on a picture like
there's Mystic pieces and this dude
built the picture wrote the diagram to
the picture gave you a map and
everything was like this is what
happened I don't know
but at the end of the day it's like it
was like we go to college or high school
and they're like all right I need to
cite your sources and it's like yeah
regardless really good that's a really
good paper but regardless how it's done
Bethesda all of them should feel ashamed
how they handled that situation but it
comes on him for not actually working
out to a lawyer and having someone look
over all this and draft up paperwork if
he didn't have contracts when we do
stuff little and I'm talking a little
chat we have a lawyer look over it and
if we're doing that on our side that
ain't no way this man should be doing
that look I hate that that happened to
him but to me this is a this is a life A
Life Lesson to him that's like look I
can't trust people yeah
depending on the size like if you give
me a half a million dollars
yeah I mean I may not stand on my square
right even like if you look at he he
anger just told you atomic heart since
then this the game is coming out next
year is his is his next work so he had
nothing in between so this is obviously
really affected him here's the thing
though I don't blame him for not taking
the bag if he's passed
I don't blame you for taking the bags
but it's just like
you put yourself in a situation because
you didn't have those bylogs in place
and now sometimes you know good people
get swept under the rug yeah I know that
sounds bad but it's just like you didn't
put the things in place to protect you
and then now you're going to have to
deal with the consequences
and I I would point out specifically
[Music]
um
the part where he screwed up
was going over ID's head for a project
they clearly didn't want him to work on
but he is like I got a push back no no
here's here's this is
they very clearly did not want him
working on the OST that's why they got
Chad working on it so why not Marty just
say fancy Services
we talked about this a couple of weeks
ago what do you mean trying to be nice
is this business if you don't want the
man working that's the frustration of
Mick it's like yeah he's not getting any
responses
they handled them with baby gloves
from Marty's perspective because this
was happening he goes over mix head
right in January he goes over Marty's
head in January before the game launches
and he doesn't want like oh if I tell
him he's not working on the OST he
doesn't want the you know Mick going out
there making public state statements
which it started to do where the game
came out but it didn't want that to
happen but I I'm looking at it from the
perspective of
if you don't want him to work on this
project and you don't want that money to
go out yeah why are
how do I put this best
if you're Mick Gordon
your number one mistake was going to
Cinemax legal okay these guys sued but
no one else played the game on a random
mobile game okay just for having the
word scroll the thing is though I don't
disagree with them on that because if no
one else is communicating with you you
have to go to the higher up right you
gotta go to that but like so you need to
tell me if you go into a restaurant
Anchorman and they they just you have a
horrible experience you told the magic
you mean to tell me that you have no
like you clearly see that they're not
responding they don't care you got food
poison you almost died you just you're
not gonna talk to the people above them
above them yeah it's like if you go work
for someone and then your paycheck ain't
coming and your manager is not
responding to why you're checking here
but yeah that's not that's not a simple
situation because he did get paid in
November yeah but then he's saying he
did extra work and this is where the
great but they didn't want that one he
didn't know about the extra work until
the game correct correct correct and
that that part is the gray area that
part I'll give you because
he doesn't know about he basically he's
submitting all these tracks then they
reject certain tracks right and then he
feels like okay I keep submitting music
they didn't like this and then I'm
crunching I'm sleeping under my desk
that you know and then he's saying the
reason why I'm conscious because I
didn't know you know saying what the
concepts are whatever so then we get to
this Loop the stuff comes out he then
finds out that the stuff that was
rejected is now part of the soundtrack
so he likes yeah what you find out later
found out in March right so he's like I
want a bag for the extra stuff that I
did and I just want the post down and we
could be good right the only thing where
it's the gray area and I don't know
because I don't know composer Lord and
all of this but from my understanding
anything you submit even if it's not
used is owned by the company yeah so I
can sit there and submit all it don't
know once I submit it I lose ownership
yeah it's them right I give it Credit in
a sense that okay we're going to pay you
for that they technically in my opinion
again see what they have to do that
right we'll get hold on for that for
whatever right the question becomes
how important this post is because
the fact that Ed and Marty don't want
this to come down to me suggests that
it's an admission of guilt that they did
do him dirty because if you take that
down or when you said this man was hard
to deal with you imply all this stuff
and then the post comes down then it's
like well maybe he wasn't hard to deal
with because you didn't stand on your
square and I think it's the Optics of
that is where this is coming at here's a
question I have too that was up for
years at this point taking it down is
that going to really fix anything
because it's already done the damage so
why don't you just take the bag
considering the damage is already done
I mean I get it like everybody that
wanted to see it sword right so now
they're offering you the bread all right
they compensate you for whatever damage
you use that belt was done to you that's
one of those bags that's one of those
things you go to the job interview let's
talk about the posts
the thing that he kind of innocently and
dumbly did was go above Marty's head
you're on the radar your 1099 worker you
don't have any rights in that regard
secondly what what people and this is
this is a general thing people always
need to understand about businesses and
dealing with businesses even even when
you're an employee of that business
management
HR anybody in positions of Power are
there to protect the company yes I agree
a company good point good point there
the the Olive Branch was the six figure
song and that is it okay we'll do this
much we'll give you this we'll
compensate you right that is our
admission of guilt right and we're going
no further his so what he's done is gone
into the into into the realm of the sort
of the public opinion right trying to
shame them into admitting wrongdoing
because it's happened before in the
public realm and either they're going to
stand on their square like you said and
not take it down because it makes them
look guilty right just eat it because
again it's been out there for two years
what does it matter at this point right
or
in in the most in in the best scenario
for for for Mick they admit something
which is not gonna happen right if I get
yeah I don't ever ever go to higher ups
thinking they're gonna side with you
it's not gonna happen never going to
they're never going to they're never
going to they're there to protect the
business
and and even if they egregiously know
that everything you're saying is true
they're going to shut you up some way
shape or something I know we went along
with this
um all I would say is it's going to be
interesting one if there's a response by
it right because this thing that he put
out is gaining tremendous public opinion
traction it's it's it's going all over
people are siding with mcguard we could
say you know whether he did what's wrong
but people are really empathetic and the
composer cause the question is do they
get a hold of it and then do they
respond to it is there more to it that
like to anger man's point that we don't
know as the receipts that Marty has to
counter what Mickey's saying because big
stuff is pretty damning it's pretty damn
it now you got that and then we got the
Microsoft component now that they're
involved right because they have now
acquired all this prior to all the drama
and what they going to do all I'm going
to say and I'll end it with my point and
then I can move on it's just that you
know it sucks because the fans lost out
I'm a guy that loves OST music I'm the
guy that bounce soundtracks buy
soundtracks all the time y'all see me in
the gym with the health as well if I got
the video game music it's motivational
to me there's nothing worse than when
you listen to something that you know
that the quality is trash and it sticks
together whack and it's just not
accurate it the fans lost out that means
that means a lot and I just hope that
the discussion opens up because at the
end of the day video game music is very
important think about this think about
Halo without the iconic Warrior chance
at the beginning you know what I'm
saying think about Fallout war never
changes when that joint hit and that
title screen ain't like it means a lot
so I'm just hoping that maybe out of the
result of this even if Mick does not get
what he wants if there's a deeper look
at how composers are handled because I
still think it could have been handled a
little bit better and we just got this
plays out but yeah this is gonna be
interesting I'm with ankle on this
though
unfortunately the way I feel because of
the Bayonetta situation as much as mixed
stuff looks air tight I just gotta chill
until we see the full picture and
there's more to this but right now I
just do filmmakers winning quarter
public opinion we just got to see yes we
gotta see what happens and well the
thing about the court of the court of
public opinion is uh where's skillup's
video
oh why are we coming
I saw him specifically where's Jason try
his piece well maybe there's something
investigation all this all this public
support I haven't seen anybody actually
talk about oh no no no they own it
though I see Sheamus Blackley jump up on
his joint I see people
okay he means like a deeper delving okay
when he's talking about someone that's
normally exposes
no listen it's gonna come out when the
hell of a Taylor thing happened right we
saw Jason schreier had an article he
came out that same way absolutely that's
Sunday I'm checking his Twitter feed I
don't see in the Articles
also the fact Jesus is blacklisted from
Bethesda for working group
the relationship is the relationship is
bad there I forgot about that yeah the
relationship is bad exactly so Jason
schreier has every reason to do it well
I mean but it also comes down to access
too so if you blacklisted it you don't
got access then it's gonna be harder for
you to get to school or stuff but I I
get your point let's just chill let's
just wait let's see what happens and
yeah just got to break it up this is a
good discussion we got to move on so I
was going to Super Chat yeah all right
guys
appreciate you man thank you later bro
uh let me see it's just a couple uh
uh
wow that's what's up that's what's up
when it's addicts got a war review
dropping what's the next game
what's the next one you're gonna review
uh after the podcast and I'm probably
gonna end up reviewing the Pokemon
Scarlet or one of those two I don't know
uh in the chat which one I should which
one I should review I don't really do
the colorless things very well just put
which one in there
and we got Sparkle 17 5 pound Super Chat
inspect the gadget capping out here for
Bethesda yo don't do it like that don't
do it like that if dude got fired of
course he's going to get replaced by
someone hush money for the acquisition
okay basically all right this one goes
17 Again two pounds we chat he got
screwed over dude rocked out no
protection yeah for real oh and I I got
a a public what uh a public call out
yeah Jazz you got me in that sword and
shield man you gonna have me in this
Scarlet you gonna beat me in this game
all right there you go we all caught up
yep that's it cool I mean it's literally
the quickest topic going I mean just
please do it this is now so look um
King's topic gotta set it up real quick
so yeah it looks like
um the new Monkey Island is dropping
return to Monkey Island
um but some interesting information we
found out about it guys going to Game
Pass but not going to um Xbox One game
pass and uh oh really yes good astute
catch by um King here yeah the long
awaited sequel it's going it's going to
be on launch exclusive on switch and PC
and um obviously the uh what you call it
the Xbox series consoles and PlayStation
on November 8th but um it does not go to
Game Pass Xbox one so it looks like this
may be one of the first games that's not
going to be on last gen consoles and it
caused little things okay you know this
is your topic like what's your thoughts
on this man well
um obviously Microsoft believes in
Generations
here we go from this point forward
the old generation will not hold us back
oh that's what we're doing Monkey Island
is out here they said no we don't want
your crusty old systems they're exactly
intensive monkeys
if you're not putting any lotion on it
and making sure that
next gen ready we don't have nothing to
do oh so you said what console is a
castle of their word yeah man you know
shout out to Phil and the team full
abdominus Maximus a really expensive sit
now man say yo Monkey Island going over
there hell no
the island is the Catalyst
we believe in Generations
[Laughter]
[Music]
man no compliment no compromises
this is this is what I like you know
because I dream about my DLC if only
if only my DLC was just this generation
only
but y'all didn't set the chance
Game of the Year a kid with this man
right here this is so messy right here
no doubt no absolute addict your
thoughts on it man what the island
Breaking the Chain of uh Xbox uh Game
Pass games being on all Xbox consoles
I don't care
you know if if that shows anything uh
that that's your sign
next oh okay there it is oh the listen
man the graphical intensity yeah there's
clearly the developer challenge exactly
yeah I mean I I mean 40 90s are having
problems
I can't I get it I get it you know I
mean it's no longer can it run crisis
You Gotta Throw monkey out of this your
lips
get that 3D Mark out
graphically intensive we gotta push that
you gotta punch that dude yeah you know
this news is out here
all right okay so is the game does it
can you find it on Xbox One proper no
it's not game based just there's no Xbox
One is there a PS4 version yes
PS5 hold on let me just make sure that
again okay it's coming you need to
upgrade yeah it's just it doesn't make
mention of yeah it just says that it's
not on the Xbox One in any capacity
which means Xbox One usually subscribe
to Game Pass can't check out with the
subscription service yeah
right so yeah interesting
Ron Gilbert you know Ron Gilbert's about
that Cutting Edge this technology
[Laughter]
you gotta step it up out here listen I
I don't know bro we're just in a
position I don't know when this real
hard stop is ever going to happen to be
honest with you this Heart Stopper
obviously obviously the thing is if the
Xbox one had sold more right
on its own we'd still be seeing more but
if it was a fifth I'll be drunk
yeah so again this is a non-installing
because it's not the case right on the
PlayStation you know 150 million
PlayStation reports out there you know
116 man
extra inflated numbers
if this is the hard stop that's funny
that's the funny photo because it is the
nature of this game I'll jump it yeah
it's just funny like I was just like I
didn't even know but I guess shout out
to King fighting these these articles
and scouring the internet for things
that you know he's one of our best in
the game as far as journalistic
reporting finding stuff but yeah I mean
it is funny because it's obviously
graphic with each other
um I am interested because if they that
surprised me okay fine you're not gonna
put it
on the console but you know what
surprised me is that why is there no
streaming option right yeah because that
that to me was the whole initiative
which is you know no console gets left
behind So eventually that the games
won't be native on there but for
inferior harder like remember when it
was like a flight simulator
you can stream to the Xbox one no
flexibility based on the technical thing
we're not that was a mandate from a pie
we put that in there but Monkey Island
we decided
[Music]
it will be interesting if this sets a
trend when Xbox One and they start to
phase it out but I would be disappointed
that Xbox one doesn't get the option to
stream more higher performance com
series consoles games to it because I
think that's part of the vision is
available
a little bit a little bit we got a
console for you got a console for you we
can say it now after this out we don't
see it before it come out that's
detrimental the last time we did that it
didn't go good but um now now since
little man is 90 over at Amazon
clearly bunked yeah we gotta see we got
to see I won't say this yeah he makes a
lot of sense because the thing is
remember like remember when nobody could
find a little man nobody could find a
series X like the prices for a 1X and a
1s
Bonkers no they were Bonkers because you
couldn't find
so like you know it people would like
they would put they were actually more
of those going out like whatever was
stock and still in stock was being
purchased yeah I I sold Jamie's for
three hundred dollars oh s uh s so it
was one of those things where it's like
the time back then warranted it right
now like you said the S is out here the
one the series that's out there you can
find the X I think more and more they're
gonna quietly sort of put that to bed
yeah you're gonna put it to bed you know
yeah yeah that's fine that's fine I
don't have no problem with the sunset I
just have an issue with give the cloud
option that you promised they could have
right because it's not going to be
resource intensive to stream the the
game today well it's a different beat oh
stop you you know what we we did we did
velocity architecture
with this one this one is the one that
y'all ask for this is the one with the
ray tracing everybody
you just can't get it I'm all four
generations I I I support that message
let's let's walk this and see from this
point on if we see more of it yeah they
just want to see if it's gonna be
pushback
Do It Monkey Island nobody gonna notice
yeah that's true who's gonna notice that
like me
it was weird is they still make an Xbox
One versions of things I think the
rocker blade let's see what happened
anyway yeah Monkey Island is the hard
cuddle
that was the bad date that was the
company
let's just see nobody gonna notice I
can't anyway
oh my God that was that message let's
get to see what Jazz get up out of here
yeah one from flame five dollars Super
Chat I heard that Gotham night that I
heard from that Gotham Knights dude that
the series s is still holding back
Monkey Island let's not talk about the
switch though
right so lose salute the flame be the
best let's get the pull get a body
honest with the recent critically
acclaimed release of God of War Ragnarok
which game do you have as your current
Game of the Year this is all hey Elden
ring the king remains champ by
transforming the soul genre to open
world critical Acclaim Choice B
boy Ragnarok comes in late outstanding
Graphics compelling narrative to win
game of the year or C I don't care we
not gonna act like satanic Animal
Crossing is not out here dominating
these streets for Cult of the land
shout out to everybody who Rock the vote
it will be up there the Lords we're back
in the building salute to anger man for
pulling up Salute to my Bros it's funny
said everybody in New York died
yesterday it took me a while to just do
it uh this podcast again I don't know I
just went anyway Lord adequate can find
people find you besides that sizzling
God will rag the wrong preview that's
about to drop you can follow me on
Twitter at Lord addict IOP you find me
on YouTube to get me addict I'm gonna be
dropping some God of War content over
there at the next week
um I probably I I will be reviewing uh
Pokemon Scarlet I don't I don't even
know when that game comes out like the
17th I think I think I'll have to double
check uh so
I'm not pushing to beat that game before
next Sunday yeah you go it most likely
will be live this Sunday following okay
no that game about Choice the post is
going to be up on Twitter the iron Lord
podcast at iron Lord podcast Twitter so
it will be going up soon that's where
you will vote for the poll no doubt Lord
saw back in the building fresh off for
wakando forever with me yes other games
where can I find people find you no work
today I'm gonna get ready to go grab up
a lady saw from the airport so I'm gonna
go do that and uh and back to work
because I always I'll be playing Vampire
survivors this weekend and excited for
penstemon and Summerville so we will
talk about that next week absolutely um
and uh next week are we doing a
prediction show yes yeah don't
[Music]
but this thing was released I already
know from from the moment I even started
this game I already knew what Eldon ring
was going to be got a game of the year
oh and I'm gonna suffer with that uh
maybe this game does win and just like
uh 2018 when I thought Spider-Man was
Game of the Year another came one game
came on I don't care really be honest
with you who wins game of the year who
wins what or what I don't partake in
this right
um but I do like to put uh notations in
time when certain games how they made me
feel so a lot of guys y'all gotta just
stop putting so much energy behind
somebody else's accolades right and
enjoy what you enjoy enjoy your stuff
I'm glad Sony took away yeah yeah I
gotta do it so at the hardest level
achievement type of thing for your for
um your platinums
it takes away a a dagger that you was
using to stab the next guy next to you
that enjoyed the game just as much as
you no matter what level it was on you
would know better than this individual
just because you finished it at the
highest level maybe he don't have all
the time that you do but he shared in
the same enjoyment that you did so yeah
they removed the way another argument
talking point that you guys use and I'm
glad that they did I'm glad that all
platinums are created equal
all all levels of the trophies that you
get is created equal takes away a
fighting narrative and gets you back
into being one we are one people we are
Gamers we are consumers now some
consumers get a chance to talk about it
like us but other consumers like
yourselves get a chance to share into
this whole great thing and you are
important because you are a consumer you
are a very important part of this Cog so
stop asking acting like you on Sony's
team like you helped build the game
you didn't do anything to contribute to
music or art direction or gameplay you
played the game just like me so please
sit back relax and enjoy in your money
handing over to the counter to the next
guy
next week where you can find me on
Twitter roasting more YouTube for
thinking that y'all have anything to do
with if this game is Game of the Year
you not but what you did was you helped
pay for it
King with the crazy boss man salute the
king I said to the message you know what
I'm saying but yeah good shows with
everybody in the chat pulled up good to
see everybody this Lords will be back
next week another one that's really all
I got but miss my Bros this was fun and
uh on that no anything else
we're good I jumped we out of here see
y'all next week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]